Auf der Maut war ein Rombling der Dome, als die Observatoren für die Nacht aufwachen. Die größten Wissenschaftler der Welt haben hier für Generationen gearbeitet, dachte er.
Ihr hört CRE, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die 186. Ausgabe und die erste, die auf den Namen CRE hört. Und einiges hat sich damit geändert, aber eigentlich ändert sich hier wenig. Denn hier geht es eigentlich um das, worum es hier auch schon immer ging, nämlich um interessante Dinge, die sich so in unserer Welt abspielen. Und ich bin auch immer noch unterwegs. Heute bin ich mal so richtig weit raus gefühlt. Fühle ich mich total irgendwo, ich weiß gar nicht wo, ziemlich weit draußen auf jeden Fall. Konkret befinde ich mich gerade in Bad Münstereifel, in der Eifel. Und sitze lustigerweise hier sogar in einem Aufnahmestudio. Das kam jetzt doch sehr überraschend insbesondere, weil sich dieses Aufnahmestudio mitten in einer, wie sagt man so schön, in einer Sternwarte befindet. Nämlich dem Astropeiler. Und darum soll es heute gehen. Und ich begrüße hier als Gesprächspartner, der das alles aufschlüsseln wird, den Jürgen. Jürgen Starek, hallo.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, das ist schon mal schwierig, hier den richtigen Namen zu finden. Das Projekt heißt Astropeiler. Das Ding heißt auch irgendwie Astropeiler, aber das ist ja in dem Sinne kein wissenschaftlicher Begriff, oder?
Genau, also wie das bei den meisten Projekten, die schon eine relativ lange und bewegte Vergangenheit haben, so sein dürfte, gab es ja einige Namensänderungen. Wir sitzen im Radio-Observatorium auf dem Stockert. Der Stockert ist also dieser Berg hier bei Bad Münstereifel. Und ganz konkret, das Gebäude, in dem wir sitzen, das Gebäude des 25-Meter-Teleskops ist der Astropeiler. Seit sich mal ein alter Direktor der Sternwarte diesen Namen so ein bisschen als Marketing-Gag ausgedacht hat.
So richtig vermarktet wurde es da nicht?
Man musste das damals wahrscheinlich den Leuten hier in der Umgebung ein bisschen vermarkten. Man muss sich da vorstellen, die Sternwarte bzw. dieses 25-Meter-Teleskop ist 1956 gebaut worden. Das war also nach dem Krieg, die Besatzungsmächte hatten noch was zu sagen. Man musste extra das Radar-Messverbot, das für die Deutschen gegolten hat, aufheben, damit man das hier bauen konnte. Und ja, dann kommt so eine Hightech-Geschichte deutschlandweit damals fast einmalig in so ein kleines verschlafenes Eifeldorf und man erzählt den Leuten irgendwas von Astronomie und Radar-Peilung und so und so ist dann eben der Name Astropeiler entstanden.
Radar-Messverbot, von welchem Zeitraum reden wir jetzt?
Wie gesagt, der Astropeiler ist 1956 fertiggestellt worden. Und als die Planungen begonnen haben, war das damals tatsächlich noch ein Problem, dass man also mit dem Alliierten Kontrollrat darüber reden musste, dass deutsche Forscher hier wieder Radar-Forschung betreiben dürfen.
Das heißt, darum ging es ursprünglich? Also hier eine militärische Anwendung?
Das war von Anfang an ein Joint-Venture, würde man heute sagen. Die Radioastronomie war in den frühen 50er Jahren eine ganz aufstrebende Wissenschaft. Und bei der Gelegenheit, wenn man schon beschließt für die Radioastronomen so ein 25-Meter-Spiegel, das ist ja auch durchaus kein kleines Instrument, zu bauen, haben sich die Militärs eben dran gehängt und haben hier einige Randbedingungen dieses Teleskops noch beeinflusst und verändert. Und ja, es ist tatsächlich so, dass wir heute hier in unserem Aufnahmestudio zwischen dem ehemaligen militärischen und dem ehemaligen zivilen Kontrollraum saßen, wo sich die Buben also im Sechs-Monats-Abstand abgewechselt haben.
Bevor wir noch tiefer hier in die Geschichte und Hintergründe einsteigen und vor allem auch mal hier die ganze Technik erläutern und vor allem auch mal erläutern, warum du jetzt hier eigentlich bist, vielleicht noch mal so kurz zu dir, was hast du gemacht? Kannst du ein abgebrochenes Informatikstudium vorweisen?
Ja, ich passe hier nicht so ganz rein, ich kann kein abgebrochenes, sondern ein gerade eben fertiges Informatikstudium vorweisen, dafür kann ich ein abgebrochenes Physik-Informationstechnik und Techno-Informatikstudium vorweisen, also schon gleich das wieder aus.
Also schon eigentlich auch beides sozusagen, das Country und Western.
Country und Western, immer von beiden nur das Beste.
Okay, und ich meine, das ist ja nun alles gut Nachrichtentechnik, mag vielleicht schon so ein bisschen darauf hinweisen, aber was hatte ich hierher?
Ja, das war also reiner Zufall eigentlich. Als ich hier an der Uni Koblenz angefangen habe zu studieren, war ich schon Funkamateur und habe mir überlegt, dass man dort vielleicht auch wie an der TU Kaiserslautern, wo ich vorher war, eine Clubstation einrichten könnte. Und habe rein zufällig bei einem Händler… Eine Clubstation. Eine Clubstation, also ist im Amateurfunk so üblich, dass dadurch kann man eben eine Station teilen zwischen mehreren Benutzern und kann eben entsprechend auch besseres Equipment hinstellen. Genau. Und ja, dann habe ich rein zufällig bei einem Händler Fragen gestellt zu einer Satellitenfunkanlage, zu bestimmten Rotoren. Der meinte nur, ja, schau doch mal auf dem Stockert vorbei, die Jungs haben Ahnung. Und dann war ich hier.
Wann war das?
Das war 2006. Dann war ich hier an einem Wochenende, wo zufällig gerade Erdemont-Erdefunk-Betrieb gemacht worden ist. Und ja, das hat mich schon mal sehr fasziniert. Und die ganze Anlage habe ich mir eigentlich einmal angeguckt und war dabei.
Und ich meine, wer hat die betrieben?
Das war damals schon unser Förderverein. Den gibt es schon ein ganzes Weilchen. Also seit 1995. Jetzt hoffe ich, dass ich mich da nicht um ein Jahr vertue. Und der hat damals schon das kleinere unserer beiden Teleskope hier amateurfunkmäßig betrieben.
Also 1956 wurde dieses Projekt hier begonnen. Das war jetzt der Zeitpunkt der Fertigstellung oder da ging es dann überhaupt erst mal los?
1956 war die Fertigstellung, genau genommen am 17. September. Da haben wir jetzt auch dieses Jahr zum 55-jährigen Jubiläum einen kleinen Festakt gemacht. 50-jähriges gab es leider noch nicht so viel zu feiern. Und ja, das war also …Und wer hat das gebaut?
Also ich meine, wer war damals so der Eigentümer, Träger, Finanzierer, der Staat?
Nein, das war die Universität Bonn, aber natürlich im Hintergrund die übliche Wissenschaftsfinanzierung. Und ein bisschen Hintergrund des Baus war eben, was ich schon gesagt habe, in den 50er Jahren war die Radioastronomie so eine ganz aufstrebende Sache. Man hat eben gerade rausgefunden gehabt, dass es da interessante Sachen zu beobachten und zu holen gibt. Und ein Teil des Grundes, dass man dann hier die Standwarte gebaut hat, war mit Sicherheit auch, dass man hier ein bisschen Wirtschaftsförderung betreiben wollte. Wenn man also bei uns im Eingang mal auf der Tafel guckt, wo sich die ganzen Baufirmen verewigt haben, sind da die ganzen großen deutschen Konzerne dabei, AEG und Grupp Alcat und so weiter. Denen wollte man mal wieder einen Auftrag geben, von Seiten der Regierungen aus. Und man wollte auch ein bisschen Infrastruktur hier in die Eifel bringen.
Und wie lange hat die Uni das dann betrieben?
Die weitere Geschichte war dann ein bisschen hin und her. Grob gesagt war es so, dass die Uni und das Max-Planck-Institut für Radioastronomie sich abgewechselt haben. 1976 ist der 25-Meter-Spiegel hier vorübergehend stillgelegt worden. Das war zu der Zeit, als das 100-Meter-Teleskop in Effelsberg in Betrieb ging. Das ist hier 15 Kilometer von uns entfernt. Und da hatte man dann fürs erste Mal geglaubt, naja, jetzt haben wir ein 100-Meter-Gerät, jetzt brauchen wir den alten Stockert hier nicht mehr.
Also die 25 Meter beziehen sich auf den Durchmesser dieser Antenne. Also im Prinzip diese dicken Schüsseln. Wenn man sie kennt, ist ja auch so ein ikonisches Bild, so irgendwie aus dem ganzen Astro-Bereich. Und hier gibt es zwei davon, muss man so sagen.
Hier gibt es zwei davon, genau.
Die wurden auch beide gleichzeitig gebaut?
Der 10-Meter-Spiegel ist ein bisschen später gebaut worden. Der ist 1965 erst fertiggestellt worden. Da können wir vielleicht nachher noch ein bisschen was dazu sagen. Die Geschichte, warum man den gebraucht hat, ist relativ kompliziert. Wir waren jetzt gerade noch bei der Stilllegung, da wollte ich gerade noch kurz fertig machen, 1979 ging es dann hier wieder los.
Also es wurde stillgelegt, weil man hatte dann das größere und irgendwie size das Meter und dann dachte man so, wozu brauchen wir noch mit diesem Klimperkram, brauchen wir gar nicht weiter rumzuspielen. Aber es war für damalige Verhältnisse, als es gebaut wurde, schon recht groß.
Es war damals, als es gebaut wurde, ganz kurz mal, wenn nicht das Größte, dann doch zumindest eins der größten frei beweglichen Radioteleskope der Welt. Wenige Monate später ist in Jodwell Bank in England ein 75-Meter-Gerät in Betrieb gegangen, das auch heute noch in Betrieb ist. Dann war hier natürlich dieser Rekord weg. Es ist auch durchaus nicht das erste deutsche Radioteleskop gewesen. Es gab in Berlin-Adlershof ein sogenanntes Transit-Instrument, das also nicht frei beweglich war. Das konnte man quasi nur in der Elevation verstellen, also nur kippen. Von dem gibt es heute leider nichts mehr. Das heißt, was wir hier stehen haben, ist zumindest das einzige erhaltene Radioteleskop der Gründerzeit. Vor allem ist es auch eins, also jetzt mal rein architektonisch gesehen, eins dieser ganz seltenen Teleskope, wo man das Betriebsgebäude drunter gebaut hat.
Also es steht nicht frei auf der Wiese und dann hat man auch ein Haus daneben. Wir sind jetzt so unmittelbar unter diesem Teil. Das ist so eine Betonstruktur, die das trägt, wie so ein Tippy sieht es aus. Da sind dann die Räume eingebaut auf drei, vier Etagen und oben drauf ist die Schüssel.
Genau. Das kennt man sonst vielleicht noch vom Teleskop in Parks in Australien, das durch den Film The Dish ziemlich berühmt geworden ist. Wir sind hier, wenn wir am Renovieren sind in unserem Gebäude, immer wieder ein bisschen am Fluchen über diese Auslegung, weil man natürlich dann auch alle Technik durch diesen engen Punkt, wo eben dieses Tippy oben zusammenläuft, durchbringen muss, aber ist natürlich schon mal ein bisschen was Besonderes. Ja und danach, wie gesagt, 1979 hat man sich dann überlegt, dass man hier doch zumindest Studentenpraktika und etwas...
Also das lag dann wirklich so richtig still im Sinne von geschlossen, keiner hier, kein Betrieb, nix, kein Strom.
Das ist schon noch gepflegt worden, war aber nicht mehr im wissenschaftlichen Betrieb. Also man muss auch dazu sagen, wissenschaftlicher Betrieb hieß hier nicht nur messen, sondern hier gab es auch ziemlich umfangreiche feinmechanische und Elektrowerkstätten, die haben also hier diese ganze komplizierte Hohleiter-Technik zum größten Teil selbst gefertigt, so rein von der Mechanik her. Und diese Sachen sind damals nach Evelsberg gegangen. Ja, und dann, wie gesagt, hat man wieder einige wenige Forschungen hierher zurückgeholt, auch Studentenpraktika gemacht. Und ja, der für uns nächste relevante Termin war dann 1994, die letzte Diplomarbeit, die hier am Stockert gemacht worden ist. Das ist bei uns auch im Verein immer so ein bisschen stehender Begriff. 90 Tonnen auf den Punkt gebracht. Das war quasi nochmal das letzte moderne Steuerungssystem damals auf einem brandneuen 486 SX ist das implementiert gewesen. Das haben wir dann auch vorgefunden, als der Verein hier zum ersten Mal aktiv geworden ist. Aber wir haben es leider aus verschiedenen Gründen nicht in Betrieb nehmen können. Und nachdem sich dann 94 bzw. 96, wo es dann endgültig stillgelegt wurde, die Uni Bonn als damaliger Nutzer zurückgezogen hat, kamen hier verschiedene Privatnutzer auf das Gelände. Wenn man sich also unser Gelände anguckt, das ist relativ groß. Riesige Lichtung im Wald mit eben diesen beiden Teleskopen und ein paar Hilfsgebäuden drauf. Das ist dann also ganz verschieden genutzt worden und 2005 bis 2006 ging es dann für uns richtig ernsthaft los. Da ging dann also die Sanierung des Geländes los.
Aber diesen Verein, hast du gesagt, gab es ja schon vorher.
Der Verein hat sich gegründet bei einer Grillfeier anscheinend, da war ich also nicht dabei, das kann ich nur vom Hören sagen, bei einer Grillfeier des Max-Planck-Instituts für Radioastronomie, die immer mal wieder gerne hier raufgekommen sind im Sommer. Und ja, die haben eben gesagt, naja, also zum Abreisen ist das eigentlich zu schade, da müsste man doch mal was machen. Und es hat sich dann dieser Förderverein gegründet, da waren initial viele Leute vom Max-Planck-Institut drin, Funkamateure, Leute hier aus der Umgebung. Und ja, also das erste wichtige Ziel war eben, den Abriss der Geräte zu verhindern und ein möglichst sinnvolles Nutzungskonzept auf die Beine zu bringen.
Aber es war zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht mehr wirklich im Betrieb.
Richtig.
Und es war auch nicht so, dass man es mal so eben durch den Schalter umlegen hätte, wieder in Betrieb nehmen können.
Nicht durch den Schalter umlegen, aber damals wäre die Wieder-in-Betrieb-Nahme deutlich einfacher gewesen, als wir es dann 2006 bis heute hatten.
Also es war dann so zehn Jahre Dornröschen-Schlaf erst mal? Warum? Also ich meine, hat man dann schon zu dem Zeitpunkt... Also Ziel war erst mal nicht abreißen, wir denken uns was aus, so zu sagen. Und das verfingen dann zumindest schon mal so weit, weil ich meine, Abriss kostet ja auch Geld, muss man auch erst mal beschließen.
Ja, das war natürlich auch ein bisschen schwierig, weil dann viele Interessen wieder da beteiligt waren. Die Uni Bonn wollte eben dieses Gelände nicht mehr finanzieren, wollte die Technik hier nicht mehr finanzieren müssen, weil sie keinen wissenschaftlichen Nutzen mehr darin gesehen hat. Und der Weg, der dann...
Lag sie denn da richtig?
Ja, das ist ein bisschen eine komplizierte Diskussion. Sie lag im Prinzip schon richtig. Also wir können heute mit diesem Teleskop, obwohl wir hier sehr interessante neue Technik reinbekommen haben, nicht auf dem Stand der Forschung Radioastronomie betreiben. Es gibt aber durchaus Aufgaben, die wir auch heute noch in der Radioastronomie übernehmen können. Das sind vor allem Dinge, wo man nicht so hohe Anforderungen an das Instrument stellt, sondern wo man eben Zeit braucht.
Die sonst teuer ist bei den High-End-Sappen.
Die sonst sehr teuer ist, genau. Und das ist natürlich auch die Studentenausbildung. Also wir hatten jetzt tatsächlich auch schon Anfragen von Universitäten der Umgebung, die halt wirklich auch gesagt haben, naja, ist doch schön, dass bei euch nicht alles immer perfekt läuft und dass vielleicht auch mal diese alte 50er-Jahre-Technik zicken kann. Dann kriegen die Leute halt auch mal mit, was da eigentlich hinter ihrem Computerbildschirm passiert.
Und das hat dann verfangen sozusagen.
Also was wirklich am Schluss dann dieses ganze Projekt gerettet hat, war der Denkmalschutzstatus für den Astropeiler. Der ist also 2005, glaube ich, gekommen. Und damit war eben klar, dass dieses Gebäude in dieser Form erhalten wird. Es gab eben zum Beispiel Pläne neben dem Totalabriss. Naja, wir können ja die Antenne oben runternehmen und eine Aussichtsplattform drauf machen. Oder so dieses Standard-Ding. Wir machen eine Disco draus. Wir haben Architektenpläne, wo man quasi das ganze Gelände mit einem riesigen eingeschossigen Bungalow überbaut hätte. Das war so alles nicht so unseres.
Okay, also der Verein hat dann quasi Schlimmeres verhindert. Und in dem Moment, wo es den Denkmalschutz hatte, war dann auch klar, die Antenne bleibt drauf.
Genau.
Dann heißt es aber auch, ich meine, so eine Struktur, wenn man sich da jetzt nicht drum kümmert, die geht ja dann auch irgendwann mal so vor die Hunde. Das muss ja dann irgendwie auch am Leben gehalten werden.
Das ist richtig. Also wir hatten auch ziemlich starke Schäden durch diese lange Periode, wo das Gerät einfach nur rum stand quasi. Speziell oben in der Mechanik, die eben durch das Wetter sehr stark angegriffen war.
Was war das so, Rost oder mechanische Schäden?
Das war überwiegend Rost. Also man muss sich das so vorstellen, dass unser Teleskop oberhalb des Gebäudes so ein kleines Antriebshäuschen hat, so ähnlich wie so ein Kran-Antriebshäuschen, an dem der eigentliche Spiegel gelagert ist. Der Spiegel wiederum besteht aus einer Gitterstruktur, die ist zum Teil aus Stahl, zum Teil aus Aluminium und da rostet natürlich einmal diese Stahlgitterstruktur weg. Andererseits läuft aber auch Wasser in dieses Antriebshäuschen rein, wo wir dann eben auch Zahnräder drin haben, wo wir Lager drin sind, die nicht rosten dürfen und so weiter. Und das ist eben dann, weil du jetzt gerade sagtest, der Verein hat das gerettet, da muss ich jetzt noch einen wichtigen Akteur hier reinbringen. Als klar war, dass der Astropeiler unter Denkmalschutzstatus steht, haben sich dann verschiedene Stiftungen hier engagiert. Und ganz wichtig ist die Nordrhein-Westfalen-Stiftung, die ist auch Besitzerin des gesamten Sternwartengeländes und hat neben der Deutschen Stiftung Denkmalschutz dann hier die große Sanierung maßgeblich finanziert und geleitet, sodass also heute so die Aufgabenteilung ein bisschen so ist, dass die Stiftung sich um den Erhalt der Bausubstanz kümmert und unser Verein kümmert sich um die Technik innen drin, macht aber auch noch viel so Infrastrukturarbeiten, einfach um es unter dem Strich ein bisschen günstiger zu gestalten.
Das ist ja eine ganz fruchtbare Kombination so, oder?
Das wäre wahrscheinlich auch anders gar nicht gegangen. Also es gab früher auch Überlegungen, das Teleskop vielleicht eine Eigenleistung zu sanieren, das hätte man vermutlich nicht hinbekommen.
Wie viele Leute sind in diesem Verein?
Ja, das ist jetzt so eine Sache. Wir sind ungefähr 130 Leute in dem Verein. Von denen sind aber, je nachdem wie man es rechnet, nur etwa 20 bis 30 tatsächlich aktiv.
Der Rest ist mehr so Förderer?
Der Rest sind Fördermitglieder. Die wohnen zum Teil auch relativ weit weg. Sie haben von daher ein bisschen Probleme, hier mitzuarbeiten. Das ist aber jetzt durchaus auch eine Zahl, die eigentlich zu niedrig ist.
Die aktive oder die gesamte Mitgliederzahl?
Die aktiven. Wir brauchen also deutlich mehr Handwerker, Experten für alle möglichen Sachen. Da müssen wir eben mal schauen, wie wir das personelle in Zukunft hinbekommen.
Vielleicht sollten wir noch mal so ein bisschen deutlich machen, was das hier alles umfasst. Wir sind hier oben auf diesem Stockert. Das ist eine Waldlichtung. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch mal gerodet worden dafür. Das ist sicherlich keine natürliche Ausbildung. Da steht jetzt dieses Beton-Tippi oben mit dieser großen Schüssel drauf, der 25-Meter-Schüssel. Dann gibt es noch eine kleinere Schüssel. Das hast du ja schon erwähnt. Diese 10-Meter-Durchmesser-Antenne, die hat dann auch noch mal so ein eigenes Haus dabei. Und da sind dann auch zahlreiche Räume mit Laboren und so weiter. Wenn man dafür mal durchmarschiert, steht allerlei Gear drin. Hier haben sich auch so Funk-Amateure quasi mit eingenetzt. Ich meine, das liegt ja auch nahe. Was gehört noch dazu?
Wir haben noch ein bisschen weiter den Hang runter Richtung Zufahrt. Noch zwei normale Wohnhäuser. Das eine ist das ehemalige Betriebsleiterwohnhaus. Das andere war ein Übernachtungshaus für Gastwissenschaftler. Das war jetzt eben auch so ein persönlicher Erfolg für uns, dass wir den Abriss des einen der beiden Gebäude verhindert haben. Denn wir haben eben die beiden Töchter des ehemaligen Betriebsleiters hier im Verein. Und da ist natürlich klar, dass die ihr Elternhaus gerne erhalten sehen wollten. Das war eben auch ein bisschen eine größere Aktion auf der Verwaltungs- und Organisationsebene. Aber das Haus ist mittlerweile wieder bewohnt. Da sind also zwei Vereinsmitglieder drin. Die haben das quasi in Eigenleistung natürlich mit Unterstützung wieder hergerichtet. Und ja, wir haben jetzt eigentlich wieder eben den Punkt erreicht, wo wieder Betrieb auf der Sternwarte ist. Also man kann hier manchmal sonntags hochkommen, beide Teleskope fahren. Es ist gleichzeitig eine Truppe Funk-Amateure beim Field Day. Und ja, das ist eigentlich das, wo wir hin wollten.
So, jetzt sollten wir vielleicht mal so ein bisschen noch mal einkreisen, worum es hier eigentlich geht. Also Radioastronomie heißt, man beobachtet das Weltall, man blickt in die Tiefe, man empfängt Radiowellen in einem bestimmten Frequenzbereich. Das ist was für ein Frequenzbereich?
Das sind bei uns 1,4 Gigahertz. Grundsätzlich kann unsere Antenne noch ein bisschen mehr, aber man will 1,4 Gigahertz.
Also nur dieses Band?
Wir haben einen kleinen Bereich von wenigen 100 Megahertz um diese eine Frequenz herum. Da gibt es aber astronomische Gründe, warum man sich speziell für diese Frequenz interessiert. Das ist nämlich die Frequenz, auf der neutraler Wasserstoff, wenn der sich in großen Wolken im interstellaren Raum ballt, eine wichtige Spektrallinie aussendet. Jetzt ist eigentlich der Punkt, wo wir ein bisschen abschweifen müssten und nochmal ein bisschen die Entstehung der ganzen Sternwarte anschauen müssen. Denn das beantwortet uns dann, warum wir sonst mit der Antenne hier nicht wahnsinnig viel machen können. Ich habe es schon angedeuert, dass damals die Militärs hier mitgemacht haben. Die wollten natürlich für ihre Radar-Forschung einen Standort haben, von dem aus man möglichst gut den Horizont sehen kann, damit man eben niedrig fliegende Flugzeuge auffassen kann. Die Antenne lief damals auch ununterbrochen rund. Deshalb stehen wir hier auf einem relativ hohen Berg im Vorland der Eifel. Wir haben also ansonsten bis Köln ist nur noch eben. Das bedeutet wiederum, dass wir natürlich sehr viel Wind abkriegen. Um die Windlast des Spiegels zu reduzieren, hat man dann Lochblech auf diesen Spiegel gelegt. Jetzt ist es natürlich mechanisch eine ganz schlaue Sache. Elektrisch ist aber das Problem, dass die Lochgröße, also wirklich die mechanische Größe dieser Löcher, die Frequenz festlegt, bis zu der dieser Spiegel überhaupt noch ein Spiegel ist. Und das führt bei uns unterm Strich dazu, dass unsere Antenne hier, also die 25 Meter Antenne, nur bis ungefähr 6 Gigahertz brauchbar ist. Als man jetzt das Teleskop gebaut hat, wusste man eigentlich überwiegend nur von der Wasserstofflinie und hat andere Spektrallinien noch gesucht. Man hat das damals also akzeptiert, dass man vermutlich nur diese 1,4 Gigahertz Wasserstofflinie hier sehen wird. Und als man nachher gemerkt hat, dass es da auf höheren Frequenzen durchaus noch andere interessante Dinge zu sehen gibt, kam dann der kleine Spiegel, der 10-Meter-Spiegel hinzu. Der steht hier ein bisschen geschützter, ist natürlich auch kleiner und der hat, so wie man das elektrisch eigentlich auch haben will, eine Vollverblechung. Das ist also eine relativ komplizierte Geschichte. Bottomline für uns ist heute, wir beschränken uns im Empfang auf diese 1,4 Gigahertz Linie. Da geht aber unter den Bedingungen, die wir hier haben, schon genügend Interessantes.
Jetzt muss ich nochmal blöd fragen. Radioastronomie, also Empfang eines bestimmten Frequenzbereichs und Radar sind ja eigentlich erstmal zwei unterschiedliche Sachen. Bei Radar muss man ja was senden und das empfängt man wieder. Ist das dann auch dieser selbe Frequenzbereich, der da genutzt wurde?
Nein, also die Radarversuche, da habe ich jetzt die Frequenzen nicht im Kopf. Das ist aber nicht notwendigerweise die gleiche Frequenz. Ich hoffe sogar dringend, dass es nicht die gleiche Frequenz ist, denn um die 1,4 Gigahertz gibt es eine Schutzzone. Da ist also auf einigen, auf einem gewissen Spektralbereich, ist dort jeglicher irrtischer und extraterrestrischer Sendebetrieb verboten. Das ist also eine geschützte Frequenz, die für die Radioastronomie freizuhalten ist.
Extraterrestrischer Sendebetrieb ist verboten? Also die Aliens dürfen auch nicht?
Mit denen reden wir, sobald wir wissen, wie wir mit ihnen reden. Nein, also da meine ich natürlich Satelliten. Das heißt, ich darf keinen Satelliten in den Orbit bringen, der diese Frequenz für Kommunikation verwendet.
Okay, verstehe, weil man schon weiß, das ist irgendwie interessant. Aber was macht es denn jetzt so interessant? Also Spektrallinie, was muss man sich da konkret darunter vorstellen?
Da passt jetzt was dazu, was wir vorher besprochen hatten, dass es bei uns immer so ein bisschen die Diskussion gibt. Nennen wir uns jetzt Radiosternwarte oder Radio-Observatorium. Radiosternwarte versteht jeder und assoziiert es irgendwie gleich mit dem Weltall. Aber der Haken ist, wir gucken uns hier eigentlich keine Sterne an. Sondern was man in der Radioastronomie beobachtet, sind die kalten Gaswolken zwischen den Sternen und einige sehr besondere physikalische Effekte. Da kommen wir vielleicht gleich noch dazu. Aber grundsätzlich ist eben die Idee, man will Astronomie in möglichst vielen verschiedenen Frequenzbereichen betreiben, um bestimmte Objekte vollständig zu verstehen. Und wir sind eben an dem Ende, wo wir uns um das Gas zwischen den Sternen kümmern. Und da ist es jetzt eben so, dass wir...
Also die kalten Teil des Universums sozusagen.
Genau.
Weil es ja eigentlich ganz schön heiß ist.
Nein, Temperaturen sind eine schwierige Sache. Das hängt auch immer von den Drücken ab, ob man die überhaupt ernst nehmen darf und so weiter. Aber grundsätzlich, ja, man kann sich kaltes Gas vorstellen.
Aber was ist daran so spannend, dass man jetzt irgendwie sich...
Also das Experiment, was ich für mich irgendwie immer am eindrucksvollsten finde, weil das eben unser Weltbild und unser Weltverstehen mit beeinflusst, ist, dass wir hier in der Radioastronomie sehr einfach zeigen können, dass die Milchstraße eine Spiralgalaxie ist. Wenn ich mir so am Nachthimmel die Milchstraße anschaue, ist das ja ein relativ formloses Sternenband. Man könnte sich im Prinzip vorstellen, dass jetzt also unsere Galaxie so eine Diskusform hat, wo die Sterne relativ homogen über den Radius verteilt sind. Man könnte sich auch vorstellen, dass wir vielleicht in einer...
Also die Erde ist keine Scheibe, aber unsere Galaxie ist schon...
Genau, das könnte auch noch sein. Das Interessante ist eben, wenn wir uns jetzt bestimmte Positionen in der Milchstraßenebene mit einem Radioteleskop anschauen, dann finden wir dort eben Hinweise darauf, dass es bestimmte dichte Gebiete gibt, wo sich Wasserstoffgas sammelt und Lücken dazwischen. Und wenn ich das jetzt mal auf die gesamte 360-Grad-Scheibe der Milchstraße verteile, diese Messungen, dann komme ich eben zu einer ganz typischen Spiralstruktur, wie wir sie mit optischen Teleskopen auch bei anderen Galaxien sehen. Das heißt also, das ist eben so der ganz deutliche Hinweis, wir sind da nichts Besonderes. Im Prinzip sieht es auch nicht viel anders aus als bei der Andromeda-Galaxie oder bei vielen anderen. Und das Schöne ist eben, wir können das heute sehr ad hoc zeigen.
Also, um das noch mal ein bisschen plastischer zu machen. Da draußen ist so das Universum. Das ist ja bekanntermaßen recht groß. Und auch unsere Galaxie, also da, wo wir jetzt hier drum herumwirbeln mit unserer kleinen Sonne, mit unserem Sonnensystem. Mit, weiß ich, was so die aktuelle Schätzung, wie viele Milliarden Sterne, Sternensysteme und Sterne haben wir so in unserem Galaxie.
Wie viele?
50 Milliarden oder 500 Milliarden. Ich hab die Zahl auch schon wieder durcheinander. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall ist mehr als man so einen Nachmittag durchgezählt bekommt. Und wenn wir jetzt nach oben schauen, dann ist es ja im Wesentlichen so dieses weiße Band, Hence the Name Milky Way. Also deswegen hat man es Milchstraße genannt, weil man das eben so wahrgenommen hat. Und wir befinden uns aber eben auf dieser, wir blicken sozusagen auf der Frisbee-Scheibe, stehend auf diese Frisbee-Scheibe und deswegen nehmen wir das eben einfach so als Band wahr oder als ja flaches. Und wenn man jetzt diese Antenne ausrichtet und da reinblickt, dann empfängt man eben Wellen, elektromagnetische Wellen in diesem 1,4 Gigahertz-Bereich, die von diesem gesamten, von dieser gesamten Galaxie, natürlich von dem ganzen Universum und dem Wesentlichen von der Galaxie ausgestrahlt wird. Und das wird ausgestrahlt von dem Wasserstoff?
Von dem Wasserstoffgas zwischen den Sternen.
Aber das Gas strahlt ja in dem Sinne selber nicht.
Genau, also da kommen wir jetzt ein bisschen in die Strahlungsmechanismen rein. Grundsätzlich strahlt Wasserstoff, wenn man den einfach in Ruhe lässt, sehr selten doch mal ein bisschen. Und zwar ungefähr, kann jetzt sein, dass ich mich um eine Größenordnung verschätze, aber es macht dann auch nicht mehr viel aus. Im Milliardenjahre-Bereich ungefähr kippt der Spin des Elektrons, das das Proton im Wasserstoff umkreist, gerne mal um.
Also einmal in einer Milliardenjahre kippt da was um?
Genau, also wenn ich jetzt ein Atom betrachte, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeitsverteilung so, dass ich im Bereich von Milliardenjahren da mal so einen Spin-Flip beobachte.
Was kippt denn da um?
Das ist jetzt was, da habe ich mich ein bisschen gefürchtet vor der Frage, da müsste man jetzt wirklich mal einen Quantenmechaniker fragen. Die anschauliche Erklärung ist, dass man sich den Spin als eine Drehung der Elementarteilchen um sich selbst vorstellt und das ist anschaulich aber falsch. Ich glaube nicht, dass man es mit Alltagssprache überhaupt korrekt ausdrücken kann, was da eigentlich passiert.
Okay, wir akzeptieren das einfach mal, dass Elektronen so etwas tun.
Genau.
Und dabei emittieren sie?
Ja, da ist es jetzt so, ich habe im Prinzip zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder das, also grundsätzlich muss man mal sagen, Wasserstoffatom ist klar, das ist ein Proton als Atomkern, ein Elektron außenrum und entweder drehen sich die jetzt, entweder haben die einen gleichen Spin, drehen sich also anschaulich gesprochen in dieselbe Richtung, oder sie haben eben einen entgegengesetzten Spin. Und jetzt ist es eben so, dass es einen minimalen Energieunterschied zwischen diesen beiden Zuständen gibt. Und zwar ist der Zustand, wo die beiden sich entgegengesetzt drehen, ein wenig energieärmer. Diese Energiedifferenz, die also jetzt beim Übergang zwischen diesen beiden Zuständen frei wird, die wird als elektromagnetische Strahlung abgegeben. Und es ist eben so, dass diese Wasserstoffgaswolken im All extrem groß sind, sodass es mir eigentlich egal ist, wenn diese...
Aber nur in diesem Moment, wo sich der Spin ändert.
Genau. Aber dadurch, dass ich mir eben extrem große Mengen von Gas anschaue, ist es mir eigentlich egal, dass das ein seltener Übergang ist. Ich sehe in jeder Sekunde Beobachtungszeit genügend Übergänge, dass ich da eine kontinuierliche Strahlung annehme.
Obwohl, das ist echt nur... Eine Milliarde Jahre. Ja. Es gibt echt viele Wasserstoffatome.
Genau, es ist auch viel da. Also ein Atom stellt man sich halt immer so knuffelig vor irgendwie. Ich habe ja auch in noch so leerem interstellarem Raum in Galaxien noch einige hundert Atome pro Kubikzentimeter. Und das ist schon im richtig leeren Bereich.
Entschuldigung, wie viel war das?
Einige hundert.
Einige hundert im leeren Bereich.
Also in extrem leeren Bereichen, ja.
Und es ist nicht alles so leer.
Es ist längst nicht alles so leer. Da gibt es also deutlich größere Dichten. Man spricht vor allem, man muss sich das ja auch so vorstellen, wenn wir hier in die Milchstraßen eben hineinschauen. Das muss man sich jetzt mal so ein bisschen plastisch vorstellen. Wir sind ja quasi auf einer Position inmitten der Scheibe der Milchstraße. Ungefähr zwei Drittel draußen vielleicht.
Aber wir sind schon relativ weit draußen.
Wir sind relativ weit draußen und wir schauen jetzt mal, sagen wir mal so anschaulich gesprochen, 45 Grad links am Kern vorbei. Dann schaue ich da natürlich auf eine enorme Strecke durch diese Wolken hindurch. Und was mich erreicht, ist die Leuchtkraft, die sich über die sogenannte Säulendichte definiert. Das heißt, ich stelle mir vor, dass vor meiner Teleskopschüssel eine riesige Säule aus Wasserstoffgas sich befände. Und ich schaue mir die Masse dieser Säule an. Und das ist natürlich in jede Richtung, die wir in der Milchstraße schauen, einfach mal genug, dass wir da was mitkriegen.
Weil da sind halt einfach Sonnen und da ist viel Wasserstoff am Start und da ist zwischendurch auch viel Wasserstoff. Also überhaupt ist extrem viel Wasserstoff unterwegs.
Richtig. Wobei, also da wo natürlich heute Sterne oder Sonnen sind, natürlich sich der Wasserstoff schon zusammengeballt hat, dann wird es für uns uninteressant. Sobald der beschlossen hat, wir machen jetzt hier ein Planetensystem auf, beziehungsweise wir machen hier ein Stern auf, ist das für die Radioastronomie in aller Regel nicht mehr sichtbar.
Also deswegen ist Sternwarte unpassend, weil Sterne sind hier eigentlich gar nicht das Thema.
Genau.
Sondern alles dazwischen. So, und jetzt noch mal zu deinem Beispiel mit der Spiralgalaxie. Was empfängt man denn dann? Ich meine, man hat dann extrem viel Wasserstoff, der jetzt zwischen den Sternen rumhängt. Der kommt ja dann eigentlich von überall, aber der kommt nicht von überall gleich. Sondern der kommt dann, umso weniger Sonnen da sind, umso mehr Wasserstoff hat man.
Naja, nee, das ist ein bisschen anders. Was wir hier tatsächlich beachten müssen, ist das Spektrum des Signals, das uns erreicht. Es ist also da durchaus nicht so, dass man jetzt irgendwo einfach mal hinschaut und dann sich notiert, naja, wie stark rauscht es denn an dieser Stelle, was so ein bisschen die vereinfachte Vorstellung ist. Sondern man weiß aus quantenmechanischen Überlegungen, dass die abgestrahlte Frequenz bei so einem Spinflip sehr exakt immer dieselbe ist. Ich habe mir das auch notieren müssen, das sind 1420,405751770 MHz. Und das Interessante ist jetzt eben, diese Frequenz misst man nicht. Man würde ja jetzt erwarten, dass man genau dort einen Spike im Spektrogramm sieht und sonst nichts und das ist eben nicht so. Sondern was man sieht, sind in aller Regel relativ breit auseinandergezogene Strukturen und die sind vor allem doppler verschoben. Also das gibt es jetzt im Prinzip. Das Doppler-Prinzip, das kennt man, denke ich, mal von diesem Standard-Krankenwagen-Beispiel aus dem Physikunterricht. Ich habe hier einfach Wolken, die bewegen sich relativ zu meiner Position und dadurch verändert sich die Frequenz, auf der ihre Emission stattfindet und auf der ich diese Emission messe. Und jetzt kann ich eben diese Frequenzverschiebungen in Geschwindigkeiten relativ zu meiner Position umrechnen. Und wenn ich jetzt berücksichtige, dass sich meine Sternwarte zusammen mit der Erde um die Sonne bewegt und die Sonne sich um das Milchstraßenzentrum bewegt und wir auch noch vom Mond ein bisschen beeinflusst werden und so weiter, und wenn ich diese ganzen Störeinflüsse rausrechne, dann kann ich mir eben entlang meiner Sichtlinie eine Geschwindigkeitskarte dieser Gaswolken bauen. Und wenn ich das eben oft genug mit verschiedenen Blickrichtungen wiederhole, bekomme ich damit eine Karte der Spiralarme.
Weil man, also das heißt die Bewegung, man rechnet die Eigenbewegung raus, ja, und dann hat man, aber dann hat man ja die Bewegung der Galaxis, oder? Wir reden dann von der Rotationsbewegung von allem, oder reden wir dann noch mal von so einer lokalen Geschwindigkeit? Wir bewegen uns ja da genauso um den Mittelpunkt, wie alle anderen Gaswolken und Sterne auch.
Die Bewegung um das galaktische Zentrum ist ja Teil dessen, das ich beobachten will. Ich weiß aus den Standard-Kepler-Gesetzen, die eben auch im Planetensystem gelten, dass die Umlaufgeschwindigkeit auf einer Bahn nahe des Schwerkraftzentrums, also in unserem Fall nahe des galaktischen Kerns, relativ hoch ist. Und je weiter ich rauskomme, desto langsamer ist dort die Umlaufgeschwindigkeit.
Ach so, deswegen entstehen überhaupt diese Spiralen.
Genau. Wenn das jemand nachschlagen will, der Fachbegriff ist dann LSR-Korrektur, Local Standard of Rest-Korrektur. Was man dabei rausrechnet, sind die Dopplerverschiebungen, die zum Beispiel dadurch entstehen, dass wenn ich nach Osten gucke, ja quasi die Erddrehung meiner Sternwarte in Richtung des beobachteten Objekts schiebt. Solche Sachen.
So, und dann schaut man also überall hin und man sieht, diese Geschwindigkeit ist da anders als da.
Genau.
Daraus kann man schon ableiten, dass es Spiralarme gibt?
Naja, das charakteristische, warum man auf die Spiralarme kommt, ist eben die Verteilung. Also ein besonders schönes Beispiel sehen wir, wenn wir in Richtung einer besonders starken Radioquelle am Himmel schauen, dann funktioniert das Ganze auch mal andersrum. Dann sehen wir Absorptionslinien. Das heißt, wir haben eine weit entfernte Radioquelle und zwischendrin gibt es Wasserstoffgaswolken, die deren Signal wiederum absorbieren. Im Prinzip derselbe Mechanismus.
Was für eine Quelle könnte das jetzt sein zum Beispiel?
In unserem Fall ist das Casio Paya A. Das ist so die Standardquelle, die es am Himmel eben, eine der stärksten Quellen, die es am Himmel hier so hat und eine der Standardquellen für Tests, die wir hier verwenden. Also was ist Casio Paya A? Casio Paya A ist ein Supernova-Überrest.
Also ein explodierter Stern.
Genau.
Wo sozusagen alle Bestandteile dieses Sterns irgendwie in so einer bunten Wolke sich um die Umgebung herum verteilen.
Ja, also für unsere Zwecke ist das jetzt einfach mal kurz nur eine Eichquelle. Der genaue Mechanismus ist, können wir vielleicht gleich nochmal draufkommen.
Okay.
Was wir dort sehen, ist, dass wir eben drei scharfe Zacken im Spektrum dieser Quelle haben, das sind eben Absorptionen von drei Gaswolken, die zwischen uns und Cassiopeia A liegen.
Also die sozusagen was rausnehmen aus diesem eigentlich gleichförmigen Strahlungsmuster.
Genau. Und jetzt kann ich mir eben für jeden dieser drei Zacken anhand seiner Frequenzverschiebung, anhand der Doppler-Shift, die wir dort beobachten, eine Relativgeschwindigkeit ausrechnen. Das ist in den Größenordnungen, der eine ist glaube ich ein Kilometer pro Sekunde, die anderen sind so bei 40 und 60 Kilometern pro Sekunde, nur mal so Größenordnungsmäßig. Darauf muss man dann eben ein bisschen Mathematik anwenden, also ein bisschen viel Mathematik anwenden und kann sich eben anhand der Keppler-Gesetze die Umlaufbahnen dieser Punkte, die ich da beobachtet habe, herleiten.
Die Umlaufbahnen?
Also ich beobachte ja quasi mit meinem Teleskop einen kleinen Ausschnitt des gesamten Himmels. Diese Gaswolken, die ich dort beobachte, auf die ich gerade mein Teleskop richte, laufen auf ganz normalen himmelsmechanischen Bahnen um das Schwerkraftzentrum unserer Galaxis, also um das Milchstraßenzentrum.
Also Casio Pyrrha ist auch in der Milchstraße.
Genau, das ist eine. So, und jetzt kenne ich eben die Relativgeschwindigkeiten dieser Wolken zu mir. Ich kenne ungefähr auch unsere eigene Position in der Galaxie und kann jetzt eben sagen, naja gut, eine Wolke, die sich relativ, also die quasi auf mich zukommt, die kann eigentlich nur an einer ganz bestimmten Position sein. Und das ist eben, diese Messung wiederholt man einfach im Abstand von wenigen Graden über die gesamte Milchstraße und kann sich so eine Karte der Veränderungen machen.
Okay, also man kann gar nicht mal, nicht so, man misst da jetzt und aus der Messung kann man irgendwas ableiten, sondern man muss eigentlich über einen längeren Zeitraum diese Bewegung beobachten und dann zusetzen.
Nee, das ist kein längerer Zeitraum. Also ich sehe ja zu jedem beliebigen Zeitpunkt, gucke ich da hin und sehe in wenigen, also ich weiß gar nicht wie lange, wir messen weniger als zehn Sekunden da dran, bis wir da eine sinnvolle Signalstärke kriegen. Und dann sehen wir ja schon, naja gut, ich habe hier Linien bei bestimmten Frequenz-Offsets, die entsprechen bestimmten Doppler-Verschiebungen, damit bestimmten Geschwindigkeiten. Und ja, damit bin ich eigentlich dann an dieser Position fertig, dann messe ich an der nächsten Position weiter. Und dadurch entsteht dann eben Stück für Stück eine Karte der Geschwindigkeitsverteilung des interstellaren Gases in unserer Milchstraße. Diese Geschwindigkeitsverteilung ist wie gesagt ein Proxy für die Bahn, die dieses Gas nimmt. Und wenn ich das eben plotte, komme ich zu einer Karte der Spiralstruktur der Milchstraße.
Und so kann man sich dann quasi selber herleiten, dass es einfach so sein muss.
Genau. Also ich finde das ist ein schönes Beispiel dafür, wie viel Nachdenk und Mathematik man auf die Ergebnisse im radioastronomischen Bereich erst mal werfen muss. Speziell diese LSR-Korrektur ist auch streckenweise nur begrenzt intuitiv und ist aber trotzdem ein schönes Beispiel, wie man eben, ja, wie man dazu Erkenntnis kommt.
Der Hobbyastronom möchte ja auch gerne mal was entdecken und seinen Namen irgendwo drauf packen. Das heißt, man möchte ja auch ein bisschen mitjagen und irgendwas entdecken, was es sozusagen noch nicht gab. Du hast ja vorhin schon gesagt, so Beobachtungszeit ist kostbar, ist teuer. Ist ja auch klar, die Geräte sind teuer, da wird viel hinein investiert, da sind Leute, die arbeiten, etc. Das wirft alles Kosten auf und im wissenschaftlichen Betrieb läuft es so, dass eben Wissenschaftlerteams einfach bestimmte Dinge beobachten möchten, um einfach ihre Thesen zu überprüfen oder sonst irgendwelche Experimente durchzuführen. Und dann müssen sie irgendwie einen dicken Antrag schreiben und das irgendwo hingeben in irgendein Büro und dann wird das immer schön geprüft, ob denn das überhaupt irgendwie Relevanz hat und ob das jetzt quasi würdig ist, die Zeit dieses teuren Superapparats in Anspruch zu nehmen. Und da ist natürlich die Nachfrage groß. Kannst nicht quantifizieren, aber man könnte definitiv noch zehnmal so viele Teleskope locker betreiben, es gäbe immer noch genug Leute, die da ihren Bedarf anmelden würden. Aber so ist es halt nicht. Das hast du ja gesagt, hier ist es eben eine ganz andere Kostenlage.
Man muss natürlich aber fairerweise auch sagen, auch eine ganz andere Gerätelage.
Ja, ist klar, aber darauf wollte ich ja jetzt hinaus. Also was kann man quasi hier mit diesem in seinen Möglichkeiten stark eingeschränkten Gerät real beobachten, wo man dann eben auch diesen Vorteil, dass man hier nicht diesen ganzen Druck hat und nicht diese ganze Kostenproblematik, worauf schaut man? Also was kann man noch beobachten? Also ich meine, dass die Milchstraße jetzt eine Spiralgalaxie ist, das ist ja jetzt auch schon länger bekannt. Das ist schön, sich das mal selber herzuleiten, aber das ist ja jetzt in dem Sinne keine neue Erkenntnis. Was sind denn so Anwendungsmöglichkeiten, wo man jetzt noch so drauf schauen kann, wo man eben auch mit so einer kleinen Beobachtungsstation mitspielen kann im astronomischen Bereich?
Ja gut, also du hast jetzt anfangs gesagt, man möchte gerne mal seinen eigenen Namen irgendwo stehen haben.
Ich übertreibe ein bisschen.
Genau, das wird man also fairerweise bei uns, muss man sagen, wird man das nicht schaffen. Es hat ja auch seinen Grund, dass die Sternwarte mal außer Betrieb gegangen ist, aber wir haben zum Beispiel mal ein Proposal gehabt, da ging es darum, hochenergetische Neutrinos am Mond nachzuweisen. Das ist ja eine Forschungsrichtung, die bei uns auf der Erde mit Detektoren mit großen Massen arbeitet. Das heißt, ich habe da riesige Tanks mit Salzwasser oder das Icecube-Experiment in der Antarktisarbeit mit Eis als Target. Da gab es ein Proposal, dass man eben den Regolith des Mondes, also dieses Sandglaskugel gemischt, das die Oberfläche des Mondes bildet, als Target benutzt und mit unserem Radioteleskop dann über Jahre hinweg den Mond trackt und eben dabei versucht, Hinweise auf diese hochenergetischen Neutrinos zu finden. Neutrinos haben die Eigenart, dass sie mit klassischer Materie kaum interagieren. Das heißt also, ich brauche enorme Mengen an Materie, um vielleicht mit ganz viel Glück doch mal eine Kollision beobachten zu können. Das ist eben so ein typisches Beispiel für Messungen, die bei uns gut aufgehoben werden.
Da gab es ja gerade dieses berühmte Experiment, wo sie sich mit ihren Messungen nicht ganz klar geworden sind und jetzt denken, die Neutrinos werden vielleicht schneller als Licht. Da jagen sie es ja einmal quer durch die Alpen.
Richtig, das muss man sich vielleicht bei dem Experiment auch mal ein bisschen vor Augen halten. Wenn es da heißt, das Zern schickt die Neutrinos zum Detektor am Gran Sasso, dann schießen die halt einfach in die richtige Richtung. Da gibt es jetzt also keinen Tunnel, da stehen die Alpen im Weg, aber das ist ja fast nichts.
Ja, aber das ist irre, also die ballern das da irgendwie los und dann schießt es einmal durch das komplette Alpenmassiv und dann haben sie da irgendwie so einen kilometerlangen Tunnel, wo das aufgefangen wird und beobachtet wird.
Genau.
Okay, das ist ja schon eine Menge Masse. Was hat der Mond da jetzt für Vorteile?
Das ist einfach eine riesige Menge an Sand und Staub, die ich da an der Oberfläche rumliegen habe. Das heißt, ich habe auf sehr bequeme Weise ein riesengroßes Target mir geschaffen und unsere Antennenkeule hätte den Mond quasi auf einen Blick erfassen können. Also Antennenkeule muss man vielleicht auch sagen. Radioastronomie neigt ja ein bisschen zu Slang. Die Antennenkeule ist der Winkelbereich vor der Antenne, aus dem man die Signale besonders gut verstärkt bekommt. Das sind in unserem Fall 0,6 Grad. Das ist also etwas...
So klein?
Wir wollen das kleiner kriegen. Also 0,6 Grad ist der letzte Wert, den ich bestätigt habe. Ich hoffe mal, dass die Kollegen das in der Zwischenzeit vielleicht sogar ein bisschen hingeschoben haben. Es ist also...
Man sieht ja immer diese riesigen ausladenden Antennen und denkt sich so, dass jetzt hier irgendwie 80 Prozent des sichtbaren Bereichs damit abgedeckt werden.
Also das ist ja gerade der Vorteil von diesen Parabolantennen, die hier verwendet werden, dass die eben die Energie, die sie aussenden oder in unserem Fall eben einfangen, sehr scharf bündeln. Es ist zum Beispiel bei unserem kleinen Teleskop, beim 10-Meter-Teleskop sehr schön zu bemerken, wenn wir also Erde, Mond, Erde-Betrieb machen. Wir können uns tatsächlich die Mitte des Mondes als Reflektionszentrum raussuchen. Man merkt also, wenn man ein bisschen daneben ist mit dem Beam. Da muss ich sagen, da bin ich jetzt in dem Experiment nicht genug drin. Ich habe damals das Proposal nur so flüchtig ein bisschen am Rande gesehen. Die Idee ist jedenfalls, dass die Einschläge von Neutrinos auf diesem Regolith am Mond ein Signal erzeugen, das in unserem Empfangsbereich detektierbar ist. Es ist aus statistischen Gründen aber ein so seltenes Ereignis, dass wir dabei quasi den Mond, wie gesagt, über mehrere Jahre hinweg hätten verfolgen müssen. Das ist eben so ein typisches Beispiel für Programme, die bei uns gut aufgehoben sind. Haken ist natürlich auch da wieder. Da müssen wir auch ein bisschen dran denken. Wir fahren hier zwar mit moderner Steuerungs- und Messtechnik, aber auch noch auf den alten 50er-Jahre Kugellagern und da kann natürlich immer auch mal zwischendurch was kaputt gehen. Das ist eben beim Betrieb von so einer historischen Sternwarte einfach unabänderbar, aber grundsätzlich sind wir also für alle Langzeitbeobachtungsprogramme offen.
Ihr habt jetzt, das haben wir auch in dem Sinne noch gar nicht angesprochen, ist ja nicht nur so, dass das Ding jetzt hier unter Denkmalschutz gegangen ist und dann wurde es irgendwann noch mal eingeknipst, sondern ihr habt euch irgendwie hier richtig die Kante gegeben und das Teil wieder auf Vordermann gebracht. Genau, das heißt die Technik, die alte Technik in dem Sinne ist so gar nicht mehr im Betrieb, sondern die komplette Elektronik, ganze Steuer- und Messtechnik ist neu.
Genau, das ging eben 2006 mit Beginn dieser großen Sanierung los. Da mussten wir uns dann eben auch mal überhaupt mal Gedanken machen, was hier zu tun ist, aber es war von vornherein klar, wir wollen dieses Gerät wieder in Betrieb nehmen. Und was wir am Anfang noch überlegt hatten, war natürlich, die existierenden Teile der Steuerung wieder in Betrieb zu nehmen. Da hat sich dann aus diversen elektrischen Problemen heraus gezeigt, dass das vermutlich nicht erfolgsversprechend ist. Es war damals einfach so, dass natürlich den Beschäftigten wahrscheinlich schon klar war, dass die Sternwarte nicht mehr so wahnsinnig lang in Betrieb sein muss. Außerdem konnten die ja auch immer jeweils ihren Kollegen fragen, wenn sie gebastelt haben, und entsprechend haben wir hier ein relativ unübersichtliches Setup vorgefunden, wo dann eben undokumentierte Kabelverbindungen irgendwo drin waren. Und ja, wo die Relais mit Widerständen zum Funktionieren überredet wurden, das wäre zu großer Aufwand gewesen, sich da wieder einzuarbeiten. Und dann ist eben was passiert, was bei uns in der Vereinsgeschichte immer wieder passiert ist. Dann stand irgendwie genau zur richtigen Zeit die richtige Person vor der Tür. In dem Fall war das ein Elektromechaniker, der sowohl Ahnung von Automatisierungstechnik als auch von Maschinenbau hatte. Und dann haben wir uns eben darauf geeinigt, hier quasi eine moderne Steuerung einzubauen, wie man die heute in Werkzeugmaschinen auch finden würde. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt eine SPS-basierte Steuerung, verwenden noch die alten Antriebe und das alte Getriebe. Und haben dadurch eben die Möglichkeit mit modernen Rechnern, nicht mit dem vorher erwähnten 486er, auch computergesteuert das Teleskop zu fahren. Dazu kommt eben eine komplette Neu-Vertratung aller relevanten Teile in Sicherungstechnik und Antriebstechnik und ein komplett neu aufgebauter Steuerraum. Da hat eben auch das gleiche Mitglied dann zum Glück mal zum Schweißbrenner gegriffen und ein schönes Steuerpult geschweißt. Ist alles so ein bisschen auf alt gehalten. Wir wollten das auch nicht zu modern aussehen lassen und haben da jetzt eben, wie gesagt, moderne Technik hinter passenden Fassaden zu diesem 50er-Jahre-Gebäude. Ja und dann haben sich zum Glück einige Partnerschaften ergeben mit Instituten in der Umgebung, durch die wir dann eben auch an State-of-the-Art-Messtechnik gekommen sind. Wir haben also heute einen sehr schön zu bedienenden, ungekühlten Empfänger. Es ist normalerweise in der Radioastronomie so, dass man die Empfänger kühlen muss. Jetzt jeden Tag irgendwie einen schweren Deva voller Kühlmittel da hochschleppen, hier 22 Meter im Gebäude hoch. Das ist auch nicht so ganz praktisch. So ein Temperaturgefäß. Von daher waren wir da ganz froh, dass wir jetzt einen ungekühlten Empfänger haben. Wir haben auch einen Spektrometer, also ein Gerät, das aus dem Empfangssignal sofort ein Spektrum erzeugen kann, das ein sehr modernes Gerät ist. Die selben werden in Effelsberg und im ALMA-Observatorium in Chile verwendet. Die sind bei uns natürlich nicht wirklich ausgelastet. Also das System könnte zum Beispiel 14 parallele Einschübe vertragen. Das wird bei uns mit zwei betrieben, hat aber für uns doch trotzdem sehr große Vorteile.
Also auch noch Raum für Erweiterung sozusagen.
Ja, das ist nichts, was wir ausnutzen können wirklich. Das Schöne ist, was mir der Erbauer mal so ein bisschen nebenbei gesagt hat, da das Gerät eben auch in Chile funktionieren muss, also auf großer Höhe, ist es eben doch recht robust gebaut, weil er meint, man merkt tatsächlich, wenn man da ein bisschen arbeitet, dass einem doch ein bisschen Sauerstoff fehlt. Also man geht irgendwann doch auch etwas eigenartig mit Technik um.
Verstehe, das heißt, das muss extra robust gebaut werden, weil die Leute ein bisschen irre sind und irgendwie ein bisschen neben der Tasse da an den Tasten rumdrehen und das irgendwie alles über Gebühr strapazieren.
Genau.
Du hast mit dem Erbauer von dieser Sternwarte gesprochen.
Nein, von diesem Spektrometer.
Von dem Spektrometer, alles klar. So, um vielleicht noch mal diesen Single Flow klarzumachen. Also Antenne ist klar, dickes Teil, die Strahlen kommen so an. Ist es eigentlich relevant, ob man so Tag oder Nacht misst? Ist das egal? Ist das Wetter egal?
Ja, da müssen wir kurz ein bisschen drüber nachdenken, was wir hier eigentlich an Signalen rein kriegen. Wir haben noch gar nicht darüber diskutiert, wie schwach die eigentlich sind. Das ist in der Radioastronomie so ein bisschen das Grundproblem. Es gibt da eine sehr schöne Grafik, die das Max-Planck-Institut immer gerne in Vorträgen verwendet, die wir dann auch übernommen haben, die eben einige typische Quellen am Himmel mit ihrer Flussdichte zeigt. Und da sieht man sehr schön, dass ein eingeschaltetes Handy auf dem Mond mit seinen 3 Watt Strahlungsleistungen die drittstärkste Quelle wäre, die wir am Himmel sehen. Also alles andere, praktisch alles Interessante, ist deutlich schwächer, als das wäre. Und deshalb sind die Radioastronomen also besonders die drittstärkste.
Was sind denn die ersten beiden?
Sonne und Mond.
Der Mond selbst?
Es gibt, je nachdem, bei welcher Frequenz man schaut, ist die thermische Strahlung des Mondes relativ hoch. Also es gibt noch einen Strahlungsmechanismus, den wir jetzt nicht angesprochen haben, das ist einfach thermische Strahlung. Und es gibt, je nachdem, bei welcher Frequenz man schaut, gibt es einige Supernova-Überreste, die auch sehr starke Signale produzieren. Aber die Nichtstandardquellen, sage ich mal, wo man also tatsächlich dann auch ein bisschen Arbeit reinstecken muss und vor allem natürlich auch alles, wo heute dann an der Vorderfront der Forschung gearbeitet wird, ist sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr viel schwächer.
Das heißt, optimal sind die Bedingungen nachts bei Neumond?
Nein, das ist nicht so ganz richtig. Denn bei dem, was wir hier machen, merken wir eigentlich nichts von den Umweltbedingungen. Man muss dazu sagen, unser Standort hier oben auf diesem Eifelberg bedeutet, dass wir sowieso einen relativ hohen zivilisatorischen Störnebel im Hintergrund haben. Also wir sehen ja hier im Prinzip Köln, Bonn, die ganzen Kraftwerke oben im rheinischen Braunkohlenrevier. Wir werden hier also einen gewissen Störnebel haben. Und ganz aktuell sind aus gewissen Problemen mit dem Empfänger heraus, sind wir noch nicht an der Empfindlichkeitsgrenze, die wir machen könnten. Also es stört uns noch nicht so, wie es sein könnte. Aber es ist durchaus so, dass wir hier ein bisschen vorsichtig sind, wenn es zum Beispiel um die Inbetriebnahme von Energiesparlampen geht oder von WLAN, von Decktelefonen und so weiter. Ich habe auch schon immer, ich kümmer mich hier im Fall ein bisschen um die EDV. Ich habe auch schon immer ein ganz schlechtes Gewissen, wenn man was anderes als K7-Kabel mit richtig guter Schirmung verwendet. Und Flachbildschirme sind ja eigentlich auch böse und so. Also das ist etwas, wo man einfach ein Gefühl erst mal entwickeln muss. Was stört uns denn überhaupt noch? Das sind also Sachen, da wissen wir von professionellen Sternwarten, dass die dort tatsächlich Probleme haben. Inwiefern uns das hier mit unserer relativ kleinen Antenne und mit unserer sowieso schlechten Störsituation in der Umgebung stört, das müssen wir noch herausfinden.
Okay, ein Handy auf dem Mond wäre stärker. Wie schwach muss man sich das sonst noch so vorstellen, was dann hier so eingesammelt wird? Du hast ja vorhin gesagt, man muss da nur zehn Sekunden lang draufhalten. Das ist ja dann schon nicht so lang.
Die Integrationszeiten können wir im Moment noch nicht komplett, da haben wir noch nicht so viele Erfahrungen mit. Denn wie gesagt, wir haben dieses Problem, dass unser Empfänger zurzeit gewisse Verstärkungsschwankungen noch hat. Da arbeiten wir noch dran. Es ist aber schon so, dass wir auf der einen Seite können wir durch die neue Backend-Messtechnik, zum Beispiel unser Spektrometer, das ich vorher erwähnt habe, heute in FPGA-Technik aufgebaut. Da haben wir einen gewissen Empfindlichkeitsgewinn und können gewisse Messungen, die früher so mit viel Aufwand im Stundenbereich am Rand der Nachweisgrenze waren, heute immerhin in einer halben Stunde relativ hochwertig machen.
Also sozusagen auch die Einschränkungen, dadurch, dass das Ding eben so limitiert ist und so alt, lassen sich teilweise durch die bessere Messtechnik und fortgeschrittene Empfangstechnik verbessern. Ich wollte mal vielleicht kurz diesen Signallauf ein bisschen klar machen, damit wir auch mal diese ganzen Geräte in Kontext kriegen. Also die Strahlung kommt jetzt irgendwie an, ja, Gott sei Dank liegt kein Handy auf dem Mond und trifft nun auf die Antenne. Das ist halt dieses Parabol und alles wird so gleichförmig in die Mitte zusammengefasst, wie das bei einer normalen Satellitenschüssel halt auch ist. In der Mitte hängt dann, wie nennt man das Teil?
In der Mitte hängt der Empfänger. Der Empfänger. Grundsätzlich, wir haben jetzt hier ein sogenanntes Primärfokussystem, da hängt im Brennpunkt der Empfänger der kleine Spiegel und früher auch unser Teleskop, hier waren sogenannte Casse-Grand-Konfigurationen, da hat man dann nochmal einen Hilfspiegel, der dann das Signal erst zum Empfänger wirft, aber das ist elektrisch nicht relevant. Ja, der Empfänger ist im Vergleich zu dem, was man so als Kommunikationsempfänger kennt oder als Datenfunk-WLAN-Empfänger und so relativ einfach aufgebaut, denn wir müssen ja hier nichts demodulieren, wir kriegen ja hier Koordinatien ein.
Ist der also neu oder ist das noch das eigentliche?
Der Empfänger ist neu, der stammt aus einer Kooperation mit der FAR, dem Fraunhofer Institut für Radartechnik, die betreiben hier in Wachtberg nochmal eine aktive Radarantenne und möchten bei uns, möchten mit uns zusammenarbeiten mit einem, im Rahmen eines Programms, das nennt sich Space Debris, da geht es also darum, Trümmerteile im All per Radar zu erkennen. Die hätten uns gerne als Sekundärempfänger. Und ja, so quasi als Nebendesign Ziel kann dieser Empfänger eben nicht nur die Radarfrequenz empfangen, sondern auch unsere Wasserstofflinie.
Und wie, ich meine, wenn ihr Radar macht, dann müsst ihr ja auch senden.
Nein, also da wird gesendet, wird aus Wachtberg. Das ist eben diese 35-Meter-Radaranlage der FHR, nennt sich TIRA, und wir sind dann quasi Sekundäremfänger. Das heißt, wir sorgen einfach dafür, dass es da keine Mehrdeutigkeiten gibt, wenn die ihre Signale auswerten.
Okay, also es muss nicht zwangsläufig aus derselben, an derselben Stelle erzeugt werden, wie es empfangen wird. Es muss nicht da empfangen werden, wo es gesendet wird. Gut, vielleicht noch mal zurück zu dem Signalweg. Also Strahlentreffen auf, werden gebündelt, landen bei diesem Empfänger, der ist neu.
Genau.
So, und der macht dann was da draus konkret?
Im Empfänger kommt zunächst mal ein Bauteil mit dem wunderschönen Namen Auto Mode Transducer zum Einsatz. Das ist im Prinzip nichts anderes als eine Polarisationsweiche. Das heißt, wir splitten zunächst mal das horizontal polarisierte vom vertikal polarisierten Signal. In aller Regel ist Energie, die uns aus dem All erreicht, unpolarisiert. Es gibt einige Quellen, bei denen dann die Polarisationsrichtung merkbar unterschiedlich ist. Das ist dann eben noch mal eine zusätzliche Informationsquelle.
Für die Leute wie zum Beispiel mich, die mit Polarisationen nicht täglich hantieren, wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Unter Polarisationen versteht man eine Ausrichtung von elektromagnetischen Wellen. Das anschaulichste Beispiel ist vermutlich bei Licht. Man kennt das von diesen Polarisationsfolien. Das Licht, das ich von der Sonne oder von einer ganz normalen Lampe empfange, ist unpolarisiert. Und ich kann es durch Zwischenschalten einer Polarisationsfolie polarisieren. Das heißt, ich filtre alle die Schwingungen raus, die nicht in einer bestimmten geometrischen Ebene, mal ganz pragmatisch gesprochen, parallel zum Tisch sind. Genau das Gleiche sehen wir eben bei Radiowellen auch. Die können in ihrer Schwingungsebene in seltenen Fällen auch mal gerichtet sein. So, und nach dieser Polarisationsweiche folgen dann zwei Empfänger, die im Detail natürlich schon ziemlich anspruchsvoll sind, aber konzeptuell sehr einfach. Ich habe einen Bandfilter, das also unerwünschte Frequenzen aussperrt. Ich habe einen Verstärker und einen Detektor. Das ist so das Grundprinzip von allen Radiometern oder von allen radioastronomischen Empfängern. Ganz vereinfacht und anschaulich gesagt ist das ein Gerät, was also Frequenzen oder was ganz bestimmte Frequenzen, ich habe ja das Filter vorne drin, erst verstärkt und mir dann diese Hochfrequenz in irgendeiner Form zugänglich macht. Und dieses Zugänglich machen sieht bei uns so aus, dass wir direkt in der Empfängerkiste die eingehende Hochfrequenz umsetzen, auf eine sogenannte Zwischenfrequenz. Das ist auch so ein Standardprinzip in der Hochfrequenztechnik. Ich habe eine Empfangsfrequenz. Ich mische die mit einer Hilfsfrequenz, der sogenannten Lokaloszillatorfrequenz, und bekomme eine in der Regel niedrigere Zwischenfrequenz raus. Das macht man deshalb, weil niedrigere Frequenzen einfach sehr viel handhabbar sind. Die kann ich durch ein Kabel lassen, ohne dass sie so wahnsinnig gedämpft werden.
Wie viel niedriger ist das jetzt als die 1,4 Gigahertz?
Unsere ZF müsste bei etwa 170 Megahertz liegen. Die kann sein, dass ich mich jetzt gerade verrechne. Die LO-Frequenz ist so um die 1200.
Also signifikant.
Genau. Und damit haben wir eben den Vorteil, dass wir diese Zwischenfrequenz über ein ganz normales Kabel übertragen können, bis runter zum Empfänger. Entschuldigung, bis runter zur ZF-Verteilung erst mal. Die ZF-Verteilung ist dann …Runter im Sinne von dann der Steuerraum, wo das Gerät rumsteht. Runter tatsächlich ins Gebäude, in den Steuerraum. Dort kommt diese Zwischenfrequenz erst mal auf den Verteiler. Und dieser Verteiler ist wirklich elektrisch völlig uninteressant. Der sorgt nur dafür, dass wir verschiedene Geräte anschließen können. Und jetzt kann ich mir diese Frequenz eben auf dem Spektrumanalyzer einfach mal anschauen, gucken, was da so ist. Oder ich kann die natürlich numerisch auswerten. Und dazu gibt es dann verschiedene Back-End-Messgeräte. Das ist in unserem Fall eben vor allem dieses Spektrometer. Und dann haben wir noch ein kleines sogenanntes Continuums-Empfängerchen. Das kommt vom Max-Planck-Institut in Effelsberg. Nennt sich bei denen oder wird bei denen intern auch immer gerne Taschen-Back-End genannt. Das ist wirklich so im Prinzip eine kleine Zigarrenkiste. Und die wandelt im Prinzip das eingehende Zwischenfrequenzsignal in etwas, das ich mit dem Rechner direkt über eine Netzwerkbuchse auslesen kann. Der Spektrometer ist im Prinzip genauso komfortabel.
Über eine Netzwerkbuchse?
Genau.
Was für eine Netzwerkbuchse?
Ganz normales Ethernet. Das ist also für mich jetzt als nicht-Hochfrequenz-Menschen super bequem. Ich habe da einfach ein Gerät sitzen, da gehe ich hinten über UDP ran und da kommen Daten rausgefallen.
Ach so, also in digitaler Form?
Das ist natürlich jetzt ein bisschen gemogelt, weil da natürlich einige schwierige Dinge durch Software abstrahiert werden, aber wir sind eben da heute in einer ziemlich bequemen Lage, messtechnisch. Der Spektrometer ist zum Beispiel so aufgebaut, das ist FPGA-basiert, also programmierbare Logikbausteine und wir nutzen das schon, indem wir zum Beispiel zwei verschiedene Programme auf diesen FPGAs laufen lassen. Das eine macht eben ganz normal Spektren, das andere ist noch mal implementiert in einem speziellen Modus, mit dem ich etwas einfache Pulsare suchen kann. Hat einfach ein bisschen andere Parameter dann.
Also so rotierende Sterne?
Genau. Also Pulsare, das ist noch mal ein Kapitel für sich ein bisschen. Pulsare sind ja rotierende Neutronensterne, das heißt also Reste, ebenfalls wieder explodierte Sterne. Bei denen man den Effekt hat durch die Drehimpulserhaltung, ist es so, dass wenn so ein Stern explodiert und dann sehr klein wird, dann dreht der sich sehr schnell, weil sein Drehimpuls, den er als großer Stern noch hatte, erhalten bleiben muss. Und wenn diese Sterne mit einem hinreichend starken Magnetfeld durch Gas in ihre Umgebung streichen, dann werden dort auch wieder Mechanismen in Gang gesetzt, in diesem Fall die sogenannte Synchrotron-Strahlung, die wir detektieren können. Und bei Pulsaren ist das ebenso ganz charakteristisch, wie man sich das auch vorstellt, alle paar Zeiteinheiten ein Impuls. Zeiteinheit kann in dem Fall von wenigen Sekunden bis in den Millisekundenbereich hineinreichen. Und das Schwierige bei der Pulsarsuche ist, dass man hier tatsächlich, da lasse ich mich auch gerne eines Besseren belehren, aber ich habe da auch schon mit einigen Leuten gesprochen, die es eigentlich wissen müssten, dass man da tatsächlich keinen guten Algorithmus hat, mit dem man aus einem Signal herausfinden kann, ob da ein Pulsar drin ist. Man geht tatsächlich hin und probiert Faltungen mit, oder probiert verschiedene Frequenzen durch. Das ist deshalb eine relativ rechenaufwändige Sache. Der Pulsarmod im Spektrometer quält schon mal den Backend-Rechner ein bisschen. Da kommen dann so ungefähr 60 Megabyte die Sekunde bei den fiesesten Einstellungen rausgeflogen. Und danach muss ich eben diese Daten, die ich da habe, tatsächlich noch mit ziemlich viel Mathematik beackern und dann probiert man zu finden, ob da Pulsarsignale drin sind.
Ist das hier schon mal gelungen?
Ja, einige der einfacheren Pulsare können wir messen, werden da aber im Moment noch ein bisschen von unseren Empfängerproblemen ausgebremst.
Also ihr richtet das sozusagen erst mal auf bekannte Objekte und versucht überhaupt erst mal den Nachweis quasi nachzuvollziehen.
Genau.
Und wenn man das dann irgendwann, also es ist jetzt hier wirklich eine Frage von Software-Engineering, Verbesserung der Software, der Detektion der mathematischen Prozesse etc. und im Idealzustand hat man mal irgendwas, wo man sagt, ok, alles klar, ich richte das jetzt hier auf einen beliebigen Pulsar und dann kommt gleich da hinten irgendwie, geht die rote Fahne hoch und sagt, ja hier, Pulsar, alles klar, habe ich gefunden.
Sodass man dann zu dem Zeitpunkt dann losgehen könnte und einfach in irgendwelchen Stellen, wo man bisher noch keinen vermutet.
Ja, das werden wir mit dem Gerät hier auch nicht mehr unbedingt hinkriegen. Pulsarsuche passiert heute auch schon mit leistungsfähigen Instrumenten. Übrigens auch eine interessante Nebendisziplin von verteiltem Rechnen. Vielleicht kennen einige der Hörer ja das Projekt Einstein at Home. Das ist im Prinzip so was wie früher SETI at Home war. Einstein at Home hat eigentlich damit angefangen, dass sie die Daten von einem Gravitationswellendetektor hier irgendwo im mitteldeutschen Raum auswerten lassen wollten. Und die machen heute nebenbei auch Pulsar-Detektionen. Die kriegen Rohdaten von verschiedenen Teleskopen und suchen darin auch neue Radiopulsare. Aber wie gesagt, wir haben noch nicht so die Rechenlast, dass wir es auf Tausende Heimcomputer verteilen müssen. Wir müssen jetzt erstmal gucken, dass wir unser Empfangsequipment vollends so weit hinkriegen, wie wir es haben wollen. Also ich sage mal so, 2009 war, glaube ich, First Light für den neuen Empfänger. Da sind wir noch so davon ausgegangen, na ja, wir zeigen so ein bisschen ganz elementar mal, was so in der Milchstraße passiert und machen das so ein bisschen als Museumsbetrieb. Und vielleicht kommt ja mal gelegentlich jemand vorbei und macht ein Praktikum. Und dann kam eben auch wieder zur richtigen Zeit das richtige Mitglied vorbei. Und ja, wir haben da einen pensionierten Physiker erwischt.
So nächtliche Momente, wo die Tür quietscht und irgendwie Licht fällt rein und aus dem Nebel schreitst.
Das wäre schön, das könnte man öfter brauchen. Nein, der hat irgendwie, ja, hat sich das hier angeguckt, hat gesagt, oh, Radioteleskop, toll, meins. Und hat jetzt ein riesen Messprogramm absolviert in den letzten Monaten. Im Wesentlichen wiederholen wir natürlich Messungen, die wir schon kennen, wie du ja schon gesagt hast. Es ist noch nicht so weit, dass wir hier neue Sachen finden. Und es ist auch unsicher, ob man mit einem 25-Meter-Teleskop in dieser Lage, mit dieser Oberflächengenauigkeit, Spiegelform und so weiter, heute überhaupt noch was reißen kann.
Aber darum geht es ja nicht, es geht ja hier sozusagen um den Prozess als solchen.
Genau, man muss auch daran denken, dass der Verein hier angetreten ist, mit dem Ziel, wir wollen nicht, dass das abgerissen wird. Und schön wäre es, wenn wir es wieder in Betrieb nehmen könnten.
Und das ist jetzt der Fall.
Genau, und heute regen wir uns drüber auf, dass wir bestimmte Pulsare noch nicht sehen. Also das ist von daher schon relativ nett.
Na gut, ich meine, es ist ja auch wirklich irre, dass man mit Hausmitteln die Tätigkeit professionell arbeitender Radioastronomen mindestens nachvollziehen kann. Dass man überhaupt auch selber entwickelt und es ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch eine Lehrtätigkeit oder eine Praktikumsgelegenheit. Man hat ja da nicht viele Anfragen, gibt es da irgendwie Leute, die mit verrückten Ideen aufschlagen?
Da leider noch überhaupt nicht. Da fehlen uns noch die richtigen Leute zur richtigen Zeit. In diesem ganzen Bereich, wo es darum geht, Messtechnik zu entwickeln, zu verbessern und so, fehlen uns noch sehr viele Leute. Aber eben auch bei der ganzen Hilfstechnik im Hintergrund. Also das fängt natürlich schon mal ganz scheinbar trivial bei der Wasserversorgung an, aber die kann einen auch ein halbes Jahr lang ziemlich ausbremsen, wenn der Tiefbrunnen mal kaputt ist. Stromversorgung ist ein ganz wichtiges Thema und die Stabilität der Stromversorgung. Da haben wir natürlich auch engagierte Mitglieder, aber die sind halt auch relativ alleine da in der Arbeit. Geht dann weiter über das Computernetzwerk, die ganze Elektronik, die man im Hintergrund braucht. Da gibt es dann eben auch manchmal Anforderungen, dass man zum Beispiel mal ein kleines Gerätchen braucht, was in der Lage ist, programmierbare Rechteckimpulse zu erzeugen. Das ist eigentlich nichts, wo man als Elektronikbastler groß drüber nachdenkt. Aber wenn man eben gleichzeitig verschiedene Anforderungen von verschiedenen Seiten hat, ist das alles ein bisschen schwierig. Da merkt man einfach, dass nicht genug Leute bei uns rumlaufen.
Was man vielleicht in dem Zusammenhang nochmal erwähnen sollte, haben wir das ja nur so angerissen. Also das ist ja hier riesig. Also es gibt hier, erst mal ist das Teleskop riesig, die Räume sind ja teilweise recht kompakt, aber es gibt auch viele davon, dieses andere Haus, das heißt, wie heißt das? Sonnenhaus?
Das Sonnenhaus, ja.
Warum heißt das Sonnenhaus?
Ja, wir sind auch gar nicht am Zehnmeterspiegel vorbeigekommen. Der ist für die Sonnenbeobachtung auf höheren Frequenzen gebaut worden und entsprechend wurde eben das Laborgebäude, was zum Sonnenspiegel gehört, dann auch Sonnenhaus genannt.
Aber da sind auch nochmal viele Räume. Ihr habt da sowieso auch nochmal so eine Funkamateur-Bereich, dann gibt es irgendwie einen Raum, der geradezu überquillt vor jeglichem Messgerät, Arten, die ich so bisher kennengelernt hatte. Also ich habe da irgendwie definitiv keinen Mangel an, was steht da alles rum?
Wir haben im Prinzip einen kompletten Hochfrequenz-Messplatz bis in den Bereich von mehreren Dutzend Gigahertz. Das heißt also Spektrum-Analyser, Signalgeneratoren, Oszilloskope, Netzwerkanalyzer, was man so braucht.
Also total Nerd-Traum eigentlich so. Okay, und eigentlich, ich meine, versteht ihr euch auch so ein bisschen so als Hackerspace?
Ich glaube, ja wie soll ich sagen, also ich glaube ich bin der einzige hier im Verein, der eine gewisse Affinität zur Hackerkultur hat, aber was wir hier machen ist auf jeden Fall sehr ähnlich wie in Hackerspace. Ich habe mir also vor kurzem, bin ich über diese Hackerspace Design, nicht Design Guidelines, Design Patterns gestolpert, die mal 2007 beim Kongress diskutiert worden sind, das können wir eigentlich voll unterschreiben, dass stimmt, was da steht.
Also das Hackerspace Compliant?
Im Prinzip ja, mit einer kleinen Ausnahme, dass mit den Spenden sehen wir ein bisschen anders, aber ich meine, das ist glaube ich auch zwangsläufig so, wenn man das in dem Maßstab hier betreibt. Ansonsten ja, ich hätte sehr gerne, dass hier das Projekt auch mehr als offene Werkstatt verstanden wird.
Gibt es hier eigentlich Club-Mate irgendwie?
Hier gibt es genau dann Mate, wenn ich welche mitbringe, und dann gucken alle anderen komisch.
Also das kann sich ja noch ein bisschen verbessern. Aber worauf ich hinauswollte ist, hier ist Platz, hier gibt es extrem viel Bedarf für Fummelei und es gibt vor allem enorm viel Gerät. Also es gibt hier einfach mehr Gerät, als derzeit genutzt werden kann. Wenn man sozusagen so einen Space braucht, wenn man in Messtechnik ist oder wenn man überhaupt in Elektronik ist oder was auch immer man mit dem ganzen machen kann, hier kann man sich einfach einbringen und man kann vor allem dann auch einen konkreten Nutzen erzeugen für alle anderen Aktivitäten, die hier auch noch so abgehen.
Genau. Und was mir eben auch ganz wichtig ist, wenn mal jemand irgendwie gerade keine Lust hat, hier bei den Sanierungsarbeiten mitzuhelfen. Wir haben jetzt natürlich zwei Wohnhäuser, die wir sanieren müssen, da geht es dann manchmal ans Abwasserrohr legen oder Stromkabel ziehen, das ist ja auch nicht immer lustig. Kann man sich ja tatsächlich auch einfach ins Labor verkriechen, irgendwelchen Krämpel machen und hilft trotzdem allen. Ein Beispiel, was ich schon seit ewigen Zeiten vor mir her schiebe, ich habe gerade angesprochen, dass wir immer etwas vorsichtig sein müssen, was elektromagnetische Ausstrahlung von Geräten angeht. Unsere Funkamateure sagen uns, dass Energiesparlampen in der Nähe von Funkempfangsanlagen böse sind. Das hat nur noch keiner so richtig gemessen und mal in Zahlen gepackt. Genauso haben wir Erfahrungswerte von Evelsberg. Die Evelsberger mussten mal eine IP-fähige Webcam abbauen, weil die ihren Empfang zu sehr gestört hat. Ich habe mir letztens auch mal eine geholt, die gibt es jetzt in sehr schön HD-fähig und alles. Ja, die muss ich irgendwann auch mal an den Spektrumanalyzer ranhängen und mal eine Messserie machen, um zu verstehen, wie sich dieses Ding eigentlich verhält. Und das sind alles so Sachen, die ja auch an sich schon mal ganz interessant sind. Die kann man natürlich gerne nebenbei auch einfach mal machen. Und ja, das ist vielleicht auch so ein bisschen die Sache, was hier so das Interessante am Verein ist. Also man hat hier, auch wenn wir natürlich den Leuten eigentlich vor allem Arbeit anbieten können, so als Hauptmotivation, aber man hat hier Probleme, die man sonst nirgends haben wird. Das sind sehr interessante Probleme und wir haben die Leute das Fachwissen und die Geräte, um die zu lösen.
Und ein super Space für Grillparties.
Das sowieso, ja.
Ja, wir haben jetzt schon länger rumgeeiert, hier das kleine Zehn-Meter-Teleskop, das ist in gewisser Hinsicht besser, das hast du ja schon erwähnt, weil es irgendwie einen richtigen Spiegel hat, das heißt, das ist wirklich so geschlossen, also wie eine Satellitenschüssel, so ein komplettes Blech, keine Löcher drin. Ist das da nicht auch irgendwie extrem windanfällig?
Das ist relativ windanfällig, aber bei zehn Metern Größe ist das noch handhabbar. Es sieht eigentlich, wenn man davor steht, relativ klein aus, bis man mal eine Person wirklich direkt daneben stehen sieht, aber es ist heute auch so, dass der Stockert nicht mehr komplett waldfrei ist, wie das lange früher war, sondern das Gerät wird heute durch ein paar Bäume auch ein bisschen vom schlimmsten Wind abgeschirmt. Das ist also kein Problem.
Die aber dann auch so ein bisschen die Sicht einschränken.
Das ist ein bisschen eine komplizierte Sache, ja. Es ist grundsätzlich so, dass der Stockert hier oben naturschutztechnisch ein sehr interessantes Gelände ist. Wir haben seltene Orchideenarten, seltene Pilze auf der Wiese stehen und so weiter. Und wir haben ein großes Vorkommen eines sehr seltenen Baumes unmittelbar im Sichtbereich unseres Zehnmeterspiegels. Ich habe den Namen leider schon wieder vergessen. Das ist ein Verwandter der Eberesche und des Speierlings. So selten, dass man den nur als Experte kennt. Ich habe zum Beispiel schon mal angefangen mit der TU München zu reden, ob wir nicht als Sekundärkontrollstelle für bestimmte studentische Satellitenprojekte in Frage kommen würden. Da bräuchten wir halt einen sauberen Horizont.
Das bringen wir auf einen anderen Punkt. Die beiden Antennen unterscheiden sich ja nicht nur darin, dass sie jetzt unterschiedlich groß sind und dass die Beschichtung anders ist, sondern die werden ja auch anders gesteuert.
Genau.
Also der Große hat eigentlich zwei Achsen und der Kleine nur einen?
Nein, der Kleine hat auch zwei Achsen. Es ist nur so, dass das große Teleskop eine sogenannte azimutale Montierung hat. Das heißt, wir haben eine Drehachse, die im Prinzip senkrecht zum Boden steht und wir haben eine Kippachse, die parallel zum Boden steht. Das bedeutet, wenn wir einem Objekt am Himmel folgen wollen, dann muss unsere Steuerung, die Motoren, so fahren, dass sich immer beide Achsen gleichzeitig bewegen. Unsere Erdachse ist ja geneigt gegenüber der Bahnebene der Erde und es ist vielleicht jetzt im Audio ein bisschen schwierig zu erklären, ist es vielleicht schöner, sich das so vorzustellen. Wenn ich mich nachts auf eine Wiesestelle und nach Süden gucke, gehen Sterne im Osten auf, das heißt, aus dem Osten schneiden sie den Horizont, kommen dann so langsam hoch Richtung Süden, im Süden erreichen sie ihren höchsten Punkt und dann gehen sie, wenn sie Richtung Westen wieder untergehen, auch langsam nach unten Richtung Horizont und dann im Westen unter den Horizont. Das heißt also, während ich so ein Objekt verfolge, muss ich von Ost nach West drehen und ich muss gleichzeitig meine Elevation, also die Höhe kippen. Und nur dann bleibe ich auf diesem Objekt drauf. Und damit es nicht zu einfach wird, ist es ja so, dass wir uns hier keine punktförmigen Objekte anschauen, sondern flächige Objekte in aller Regel.
Aber ich habe noch nicht so ganz verstanden, wie jetzt diese Drehung eigentlich ist. Also man kann diese Schüssel quasi hoch und runter fahren, das ist die Elevation.
Genau, das ist die Elevation.
Und wenn ich jetzt an dem Azimut drehe, was dreht sich dann? Dann dreht sich das um die eigene Achse.
Genau, dann dreht sich das komplette Gerät um die eigene Achse, also quasi von Ost nach West.
Okay, und wie ist das bei dem anderen?
Das andere hat eine geneigte Drehachse und eben auch eine ganz normale Kippachse, wie wir es hier drüben haben. Und der Trick ist, durch die Neigung der Drehachse, das kennt man von ganz vielen Kaufhaus-Teleskopen, wie man die auch so als Hobbyastronom kaufen kann, muss ich nur noch um diese eine geneigte Drehachse drehen, und zwar mit konstanter Geschwindigkeit und bleibe auf jedem Himmelsobjekt drauf.
Ah, also sie führt sozusagen automatisch nach?
Genau. Die Achse ist parallel zur Erdachse und unser kleines Teleskop, weil das eben früher zur Sonnenbeobachtung genutzt worden ist, hat einen Synchronmotor drin, der aus den 50 Hertz Netzfrequenz eine Drehgeschwindigkeit macht, sodass der Spiegel den ganzen Tag auf der Sonne drauf bleibt. Ich fahre also morgens an den Punkt am Horizont, wo die Sonne aufgehen wird, gebe, sobald die Sonne im Blick fällt, Strom auf den Synchronmotor und bin drauf.
So, jetzt kommen wir noch zum anderen Unterschied. Dadurch, dass das Ding anders beschichtet und gebaut ist, kann man jetzt einen sehr viel größeren Frequenzbereich detektieren mit der kleinen Schüssel. Vorhin hatten wir dieses relativ schmale Band, eben diese 1,4 Gigahertz Wasserstoff etc. Und wie ist das jetzt bei dem kleinen?
Der kleine Spiegel wurde, das wissen wir sicher, auf jeden Fall mal bis 35 Gigahertz eingesetzt. Der könnte vermutlich sogar bis in den 70 Gigahertz Bereich rein benutzt werden. Er ist im Moment mit einem 10 Gigahertz Transceiver bestückt, das heißt also mit einem Sendeempfänger, den unsere Funkamateure für Erdemund-Erdepetrieb nutzen. Und wenn wir es schon von den unterschieden zwischen den beiden Teleskopen haben, der kleine Spiegel ist auch noch ein Kasse-Gran-System, das habe ich vorher schon mal kurz erwähnt. Das heißt, der Sendeempfänger sitzt quasi hinter dem Hauptspiegel und im Brennpunkt, oder kurz hinter dem Brennpunkt des Teleskops gibt es noch mal einen kleinen Hilfsspiegel, der die Wellen nochmal umlenkt. Hat einen ganz pragmatischen Vorteil, für einen Empfängerwechsel muss ich nicht immer oben in den Fokuspunkt klettern, sondern ich kann einfach von hinten an den Spiegel ran.
Aber ich meine, wenn das Ding jetzt... Entschuldigung, wo ging es nochmal los? Also bis 10 Gigahertz?
Bei 10 Gigahertz haben wir im Moment die Technik drin.
Ach so, bei 10 Gigahertz, also um 10 Gigahertz herum.
Genau.
Okay, das ist ja dieses X-Band. Also was kann man damit dann detektieren?
Mit dem X-Band muss ich zunächst mal sagen, diese ganzen Buchstabenbezeichnungen für die Bänder sind mir immer ein bisschen unsympathisch. Ich bin da mehr so der Frequenzmensch. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher, ob wir da noch im üblichen X-Band drin sind. Es ist der Amateurfunkbereich bei 10 Gigahertz.
Ja, also X-Band ist so 8 bis 12 ungefähr.
Und damit kann man im Prinzip die thermische Radostrahlung des Mondes relativ gut detektieren, aber wir nutzen es eben hauptsächlich nicht als astronomisches Instrument, sondern wirklich für einen Amateurfunkbetrieb.
Aber du hast ja gesagt, es ist zur Sonnenbeobachtung gedacht gewesen.
Richtig, das war früher bei anderen Frequenzen.
Und was hat man da beobachtet?
Da ging es initial darum, dass man sich überhaupt mal einen Überblick verschaffen wollte, wie sich die Sonne im Radiobereich verhält.
Also überhaupt erst mal rauskriegen muss, was kommt da überhaupt an?
Und es ist natürlich immer so, wenn man diese Möglichkeiten hat, geht man auch mal systematisch hin und prüft bei verschiedenen Frequenzen, was dazu passiert. Das heißt, es sind dort also auch Empfänger und Radiometer getestet worden. Das ist natürlich auch ein gewisser Aufwand, die auf verschiedenen Frequenzen jeweils funktionsfähig zu kriegen. Und bei der Sonne kommt ja noch dazu, dass die diesen elfjährigen Sonnenfleckenzyklus hat, oder diesen elfjährigen Aktivitätszyklus. Und es ist natürlich dann auch interessant, mal über diese elf Jahre hinweg die Veränderungen in der Radiostrahlung der Sonne zu beobachten.
Aber das ist jetzt hier nicht mehr der Fokus, sondern das Ding wird im Wesentlichen für Amateurfunk benutzt.
Genau.
Aber ich meine, Amateurfunk mit einem 10-Meter-Spiegel?
Ja.
Das ist aber jetzt auch irgendwie so ein bisschen, ich hab den längsten...
Es hat schon seine Vorteile.
Naja, das ist kein Zweifel, aber ich meine, was erschließt sich dann einem? Also kommt man dann besonders weit?
Naja, also so eine Grundidee im Amateurfunk ist ja, ich will weltweit Funkbetrieb machen und ich will eben nicht, so wie das heute beim Handy oder beim Internet der Fall ist, irgendwie nach zwei Kilometern schon auf den Repeater gehen und von da aus geht's ins Glasfasernetz, sondern ich will meine erzeugte Welle um die Welt schicken und quasi ohne weitere Hilfeleistung rumkommen. Und es ist jetzt so, dass auf Frequenzen höher als der obersten benutzbaren Kurzwellenfrequenz, das ist sehr von der Sonnenfleckenaktivität abhängig, aber ich sag mal so ganz grobe Hausnummer sind 15 Megahertz, da habe ich auf einmal das Problem, dass meine abgestrahlte Energie nicht mehr von der Atmosphäre reflektiert wird und wunderschön um die Erde rumgeleitet wird. Je höher die Frequenz ist, desto mehr fühlt sich diese Funkerei dann an, wie so Sichtfunk. Ja, ich muss meine Gegenstation sehen. Genau. Und bei 10 Gigahertz ist das sehr extrem. Also da habe ich im Prinzip ohne Sichtverbindung wenig Chancen. Und jetzt gab es eben die Idee, das ist nicht, auch wenn das viele Funkamateure immer gerne erzählen, das ist nicht auf dem Mist der Funkamateure gewachsen, sondern das war eine Idee der US Navy, aus der Zeit, bevor es Kommunikationssatelliten gab. Naja, ich könnte doch eigentlich, wenn ich da jetzt so ein Schiff auf dem Pazifik habe, könnte ich doch eigentlich den Mond als Reflektor verwenden und damit eine hochqualitative Funkverbindung in die Staaten herstellen. Das hat man mal getestet im Projekt Moonbounce. Da gibt es auch floating im Netz schöne Bilder rum, wie die Besatzung eines Flugzeugträgers auf dem Deck das Wort Moonbounce bildet. Das Ganze wurde aus dem Flugzeug fotografiert und dieses Bild wurde dann aus dem Pazifik über den Mond in die USA übertragen. Man hat zum Glück ziemlich kurz danach Kommunikationssatelliten gehabt und musste sich diesen Stress nicht antun.
Aber es hat funktioniert.
Es hat funktioniert und es hat vor allem noch ein sehr, sehr interessantes, aber unglaublich spinnertes Projekt nebenbei hervorgebracht, nämlich das Projekt PAMOR, Passive Moon Relay. Das war eine Idee der US-Geheimdienste, die sich überlegt haben, na ja, wenn das sendeseitig geht, also wenn eins unserer Schiffe quasi über den Mond senden kann und wir empfangen das, dann brauchen wir doch eigentlich nur eine etwas größere und empfindlichere Antenne und den Mond und dann können wir die ganze Sowjetunion auf einmal abhören. Und das hat dann dazu geführt, dass man in Sugar Graf eine 180-Meter-Antenne geplant hat. Das ist also zum Vergleich Evelsberg als eins der größten frei beweglichen Radioteleskope heute, ist 100 Meter im Durchmesser. Das war schon sehr gigantomanisch. Man hat scheinbar den Drehzapfen noch gegossen und dann gemerkt, dass das ganze statisch nicht funktioniert hätte. Also hat es das leider nie gegeben. Und ja, die ganze Sache ist dann etwas in der Versenkung verschwunden. Und Moonbounce ist eben heute eine Amateurfunksache. Ganz konkret sieht das bei uns eben so aus, dass auf...
Übrigens, Moon Relay haben sie geschrieben.
Stimmt.
Aber Moonbounce scheint so der Begriff zu sein, der hier trotzdem kommt.
Ja, das sieht heute eben so aus.
Hat das funktioniert irgendwie?
Also dieses eine Bild, was da im Netz rumgeistert ist, ist wohl tatsächlich diesen Weg gegangen, ja.
Aber ich meine jetzt, diese ganze Sowjetunion abhören, das ist doch ein bisschen verrückt, oder?
Die Frage, ob es überhaupt funktioniert hätte, kann ich nicht beantworten.
Wie weit sind sie denn gekommen?
Wie gesagt, sie haben den Drehzapfen gebaut und dann gemerkt, dass es statisch nicht funktioniert hätte und die ganze Funktion zusammengekracht wäre. Dann haben sie es bleiben lassen. Angeblich steht der Zapfen und die Betonplatte sogar noch. Muss man mal gucken, Sugar Graf, wo auch immer das ist. Was wir heute hier machen, sieht eben so aus, dass es weltweit immer so etwa 30 bis 40 Stationen gibt, die bei den Wettbewerben aktiv sind, die in aller Regel ähnlich ausgestattet sind wie wir. Das heißt, da gibt es weltweit auch einige Leute, die so einen 6-10-Meter-Spiegel im Vorgarten stehen haben. Das Schöne ist, dass wir einen etwas größeren Spiegel haben, als wir eigentlich bräuchten, haben wir eine gewisse Gewinnreserve. Das heißt, unser Signal ist eigentlich etwas stärker, als wir es bräuchten, um ein zuverlässiges Echo zu kriegen. Das heißt vor allem, im Gegensatz zu den meisten anderen Stationen, die mit Mühe und Not Mausetelegraphie reflektiert kriegen, das ist ein relativ robustes Verfahren, können wir ganz normal Sprechfunk vom Mond reflektieren lassen. Das klingt etwas wirr. Das hängt damit zusammen, dass der Mond ja als Reflektor relativ schlecht geeignet ist. Er ist vor allem falsch rumgekrümmt. Dann hat man Laufzeitunterschiede zwischen den Wellen, die vom Zentrum reflektiert werden und denen, die vom Rand reflektiert werden und so weiter.
Wie der ist falsch rumgekrümmt?
Naja, wenn ich da oben einen idealen Reflektor haben wollte, würde ich einen Parabol-Spiegel hinstellen.
Kann man nicht in so einen Grad erzielen?
Das wäre natürlich noch mal eine Steigerung. Wir sind immerhin mal so weit, dass wir die Mitte des Mondes finden. Und es ist auf jeden Fall sehr beeindruckend. Also schon mal ganz einfaches Experiment. Man drückt unten seine Morse-Taste, schickt einen Punkt raus und zweieinhalb Sekunden später kommt dieser saubere Punkt völlig verrauscht und zerfleddert von der langen Reise zurück. Also zweimal durch die Ionosphäre und dann eben noch die Störungen an der Mondgeometrie. Da kriegt man mal ein sehr gutes Gefühl für diese Entfernungen.
Zweieinhalb Sekunden.
Genau.
Hin und zurück.
Das ist also auf jeden Fall eine sehr beeindruckende Sache, ja.
Hat das irgendeinen praktischen Nutzen, außer dass man weiß, dass das so diesen Weg genommen hat oder kann man da jetzt auch irgendwas abtasten?
Man kann natürlich auch einiges zurückrechnen. Einmal natürlich die Mondentfernung, dann durch die Doppler-Shift zwischen dem ausgesandten und empfangenen Signal, die Relativbewegung des Mondes zur Erde. Der ändert ja seine Entfernung auch ein bisschen. Und grundsätzlich bei allem, was Empfang von Signalen vom Mond angeht, kann man sich natürlich auch immer die thermische Radiostrahlung des Mondes anschauen.
Die im Wesentlichen die reflektierte Energie der Sonne ist, weil das Ding ja nun selber keine Thermik hat.
Ja, aber das Interessante ist, dass man je nach Frequenz eben sieht, dass diese Wärmestrahlung aus tiefen Mondschichten kommt. Es ist also so, dass ich, wenn ich...
Gespeicherte Energie?
Ja, das ist jetzt auch wieder so was, was im Audio ganz schwer zu erzählen ist.
Also...
Im Audio muss man immer alles ganz einfach erklären.
Wir malen ein Bild für den Hörer.
Genau.
Also, ich sehe auf verschiedenen Frequenzen die Maxima in der thermischen Strahlung des Mondes zu unterschiedlichen Zeiten und das ist immer nach Vollmond. Ich würde ja davon ausgehen, dass zu Vollmond, wo die sonnenbeschiedene Seite des Mondes zu mir her zeigt, ich eine maximale Strahlung messe. Weil klar, der ganze Mond ist warm. Es ist aber so, dass ich auf bestimmten Frequenzen dieses Maximum des maximal warmen Mondes erst einige Tage nach Vollmond sehe. Und das interpretiert man ebenso, dass da die Wärme aus tieferen Mondschichten dann langsam an die Oberfläche kommt und erst dort abgestrahlt wird.
Ahja, verstehe, das heißt, der heizt sich auf und dann ein paar Tage später kriecht diese ganze Hitze, das ganze warme Gestein, das kriecht dann quasi nach außen, also nicht das Gestein, sondern die Wärme und strahlt dann nochmal ab und dann ist es nochmal wärmer als es vorher war?
Nein, wie gesagt, also das hängt nur in bestimmten Bereichen ist es dann maximal. Genau, also das ist eine frequenzabhängige Sache. Und ansonsten, wie gesagt, ist eben grundsätzlich diese, diese Mohnbauernsgeschichte ist natürlich auch für uns ein bisschen so eine Vorbereitung, dass wir auch mal über Satellitenfunk nachdenken. Grundsätzlich gibt es natürlich Amateurfunksatelliten da draußen, die auch von Amateuren gebaut, finanziert und betrieben werden und prinzipiell sind wir mit unseren beiden Antennen hier natürlich auch eine Station, die mal über Satellitenkontrolle zum Beispiel eben für studentische Satelliten oder für Amateurfunksatelliten nachdenken könnte.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile einige Möglichkeiten, so Kleinstsatellitchen noch so als Payload einfach bei Missionen mit dazu zu tun, die einfach noch so ein bisschen was über haben.
Genau.
Und die können dann so Sputnik-Style einfach so ein bisschen vor sich hin piepen oder vielleicht auch ein paar sinnvolle Dinge tun, aber es wäre so das Minimum. Und dann braucht man ja auch eine Bodenstation, weil ohne Bodenstation kein Kontakt und dazu braucht man so eine Schüssel und da würde das Zehn-Meter-Tal auch locker ausreichen.
Na ja, was da immer ausreicht, das ist eine schwierige Sache, die muss man im Einzelfall ausrechnen. Da gibt es dann ein sogenanntes Link-Budget, da muss man also ausrechnen, wie weit ist der Satellit weg, wie groß ist dessen Antenne, wie empfindlich ist dessen Empfänger, wie leistungsstark ist dessen Sender, wie sieht es bei uns aus und kommen wir damit unterm Strich hin. Wir haben im Prinzip hier die Auswahl zwischen zwei Antennen und es ist im Moment so, dass der 10-Meter-Spiegel natürlich eine kleinere Fläche damit auch einen etwas kleineren Gewinn hat, aber der ist schneller. Unser 25-Meter-Teleskop ist in der Nachführgeschwindigkeit für manche Satelliten, gerade im niedrigen Erdorbit, einfach nicht flott genug.
Fliegt zu schnell vorbei. Wie schnell dreht er sich? Also wenn man jetzt hier das große Teil so mit Max-Speed drehen würde?
Ja, Maximalgeschwindigkeit ist so eine Sache. Wir haben im Moment aus Gründen des Schutzes der alten Mechanik die Drehzahl ein bisschen reduziert und sind jetzt bei etwa acht Minuten für eine volle Umdrehung. Wir können da noch mehr rausholen. Dann kommen wir aber in einen Bereich, wo es eben keine harten Grenzwerte mehr gibt. Da kann man dann eben nicht mehr sagen, das ist zu schnell, sondern dann muss man halt irgendwann sagen, jetzt schäppert es aber langsam ein bisschen arg laut. Und das ist eigentlich etwas, wo wir ohne Not noch nicht hin wollen. Und die kleine? Da habe ich jetzt gerade keine Zahlen im Kopf. Die ist aber für Satelliten im normalen LEO schnell genug, also Low Earth Orbit.
Was muss man mir jetzt vorstellen? Die dreht sich in einer Minute einmal im Kreis oder irgendwie?
Ich würde mal eher zwei Minuten sagen, aber die kriegt man relativ schnell.
Ja, also, dann müsste man halt schauen, ob man das richtige Frequenzband dann auch hat für die Satellitenkommunikation. Das kann man sich wahrscheinlich nicht beliebig aussuchen.
Ja, es ist auch leider nicht beliebig, aber wir haben zumindest einen ziemlich großen Spielraum. An der großen Antenne eben, wie gesagt, bis 6 Gigahertz geht sie eben. An der kleinen Antenne geht es dann los, dass man nicht mehr sehr, also sehr niedrige Frequenzen würden wiederum ein so großes Horn am Empfänger benötigen. Dass ich irgendwann ganz nah an den Sekundärspiegel komme, und dann habe ich ein geometrisches Problem. Das ist also alles irgendwie so eine Sache, wo sehr viele Parameter gegenseitig voneinander abhängen. Wir haben das jetzt mal ganz grob für ein Satellitenprojekt namens, es weiß ich nicht, SMO oder SMOS, nee, SMO muss das heißen, der Uni München mal angeschaut, da hat man mal Vorüberlegungen angestellt. Das ist der European Student Moon Orbiter, die wollen mit einem relativ großen Satellitenbus einen Mond Orbiter realisieren. Da sind wir technisch an so ein paar Herausforderungen gestoßen, da ist nicht ganz klar, ob wir die packen würden, aber ja, das waren wie gesagt mal Vorwärtsüberlegungen. Denn das Problem ist natürlich jetzt gerade bei so einer Mission, die wird irgendwo im niedrigen Erdorbit ausgesetzt, das heißt da brauche ich ein Teleskop, das schnell tracken kann, eine Antenne, die schnell tracken kann. Dann geht es auf den Transit zum Mond und irgendwann in den Mondorbit. Da brauche ich dann viel Gewinn, um dieses entfernte Objekt noch zu erreichen. Und bei allem brauche ich eben wiederum viel Zeit vor Ort. Und das ist eben der Punkt, wo man sich dann eben Gedanken über den Stockert gemacht hat, denn Zeit ist hier eigentlich vorhanden.
Also wenn ich das so richtig sehe, eigentlich steht ihr hier noch ganz am Anfang. Also hier gibt es einfach Platz und Gerät und Möglichkeiten. Und eigentlich kann man jetzt mal anfangen, hier so richtig loszuspinnen und sich alles Mögliche einfallen zu lassen.
Ja, wobei ich fast mal sagen würde, so richtig am Anfang stehen wir gar nicht mehr. Also man steht hier, andersrum gesagt, eigentlich stehen wir hoffentlich immerhin, immer weiterhin auch am Anfang.
Also ein Anfang ist gemacht.
Wir haben viel mehr erreicht, als wir uns 2005 und 2006, wo wir hier mal, also gerade 2006 und 2007, sag ich mal, waren für mich auch ziemlich ungemütliche Jahre, weil wir da hier angefangen haben, mal zu entrümpeln, ganz viel Zeug rauszuwerfen und es waren alles destruktive Arbeiten irgendwie. Und ja, wir haben eigentlich alles erreicht, was wir damals vorhatten und machen jetzt eigentlich schon deutlich mehr und sehen jetzt dadurch, dass wir mehr können, was wir alles noch nicht können. Das ist also jetzt irgendwie so dieser typische Wissenschaftseffekt, sobald man was kann, merkt man erstmal, was es dahinter noch alles gibt und was man gerne auch machen wollte.
Raum für Erweiterung.
Auf jeden Fall.
Tja, und was würdest du jetzt am liebsten machen?
Also ich persönlich finde diese Satelliten-Kontrollgeschichte sehr spannend. Es ist aber so, dass wir da auch ein bisschen fremdbestimmt sind. Das ist das, was ich vorher so bei diesen Hackerspaces so ein bisschen am Rande angedeutet habe. Wir sind hier natürlich auf die Zusammenarbeit mit ganz vielen anderen Leuten angewiesen und auch auf Spenden und Sachspenden und Leute, die uns Geräte bauen und so weiter. Das heißt aber halt auch, dass wir es uns nicht komplett frei raussuchen können, was wir machen. Vor dem Hintergrund ist natürlich das, was ich am liebsten mache, immer das, was das Projekt weiter am Laufen hält. Weil da muss man halt mal in den sauren Apfel beißen. Manchmal muss man dann eben Sachen machen, die jetzt nicht so ganz die hohe Priorität für einen selber haben, einfach damit es hier weitergeht. Aber wie gesagt, wenn jetzt alle anderen konstraten Zweck wären, würde ich gerne auf einem Spiegel zumindest Satellitenkontrolle und Empfang machen können. Aber die Radioastronomie ist natürlich auch eine hochspannende Sache. Wobei ich mich da immer ein bisschen vor dem Moment fürchte, wo wir dann merken, okay, jetzt geht es nicht weiter, weil jetzt kommen wir langsam in die Störglocke hier von Köln und jetzt haben wir einfach mal das Ende erreicht. Das ist noch nicht so, aber wird leider irgendwann kommen.
Wie interdisziplinär ist denn so die Gruppe, die sich hier bisher um alles kümmert? Sind das so im Wesentlichen alles so Astrofreaks oder Ingenieure? Hast du ja gesagt, vom Hacker-Style fühlst du dich noch ein bisschen unterrepräsentiert?
Ja, genau. Also das ist sehr breit gefächert. Wir haben natürlich viele Funk-Amateure, die als Hintergrund meistens Nachrichtentechnik oder Messtechnik haben. Wir haben keine, das heißt noch, wir haben einen Radioastronomen im Verein. Wir haben aber keine optischen Astronomen, soweit ich weiß, zumindest nicht unter den aktiven Mitgliedern.
Habt ihr denn hier auch Teleskope?
Wir haben hier auch Teleskope, wir sind im Hobbybereich aufgestellt, haben einige Spiegelteleskope bis rauf zu einem Elfzöller, denken auch gerade noch über die Anschaffung von Sonnenteleskopen nach. Das ist aber im Moment, ja, ist ein bisschen nachrangig leider. Wir haben hier zwar einen sehr schönen, tollen, dunklen Himmel und haben auch die ganze Infrastruktur vor Ort, aber auch eben dafür einfach keine Zeit.
Ja gut, aber in dem Moment, wo sich da jemand einbringen würde?
Genau, also es gibt Platz und so weiter. Und ansonsten, was wir natürlich jetzt ein bisschen vernachlässigt haben bisher, sind die Leute, die hier überhaupt die ganze Infrastruktur am Laufen halten. Man braucht natürlich auch Experten für Elektrotechnik, Brunnenbau. Wir haben ja einen eigenen Tiefbrunnen. Irgendjemand muss einem auch mal sagen, hier, dieser Ritz im Putz, der ist noch okay und der ist nicht mehr okay und den flickst du jetzt mal. Dann haben wir jetzt hier auch auf die etwas schwierige Art gelernt, wie man Häuser energie-technisch optimiert. Wir haben im Bereich Telekommunikation und Netzwerktechnik im Prinzip alles selber lernen müssen. Ich habe hier auch erst mal gemerkt, wo dann so die Haken sind, wenn man zum Beispiel Linux als ernsthaftes Produktivsystem einsetzt. Also ich habe jetzt hier zum ersten Mal eben mit Rechnern zu tun gehabt, wo sich halt tatsächlich auch Leute ernsthaft ärgern, wenn die ausfallen. Beziehungsweise an einem der Rechner hängen eben die 90 Tonnen Stahl hier dran. Das ist auch eine gute Motivation, dass der keinen Blödsinn macht. Das sind alles so Sachen. Im Prinzip brauchen wir hier, um diese Anlage in Betrieb zu halten, eigentlich alles und jeden. Also Naturschutz haben wir zum Beispiel auch noch gar nicht angesprochen. Das ist natürlich auch eine wichtige Sache hier oben. Und auch ganz pragmatisch einfach mal Leute, die sich ein bisschen hier um Haushalt kümmern. Also ich meine, es ist glaube ich jedem höher klar, was passiert, wenn man hier irgendwie 20 Elektrotechnik-Leute irgendwie in Weilchen mit einer Küche in Ruhe lässt. Das ist auch nicht gut.
Ja gut, muss man nur die richtigen Perspektiven hier bieten. Aber ich habe so den Eindruck, ich meine, ich habe das jetzt hier alles nur in der Nacht bisher mitbekommen. Und außer dir jetzt ja auch noch sonst niemanden mitbekommen. Aber das ist halt einfach... Space trifft es hier echt ganz gut. Und in gewisser Hinsicht mit dem Platz ist es auch vielleicht... Wer schon immer vom Nördhimmel geträumt hat, hier ist man ihm recht nah. Und das ist so im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Haben wir denn noch irgendwas ganz Substantielles vergessen?
Ja, ich habe eigentlich noch zwei Sachen, die ich noch gerne angesprochen hätte. Und du hast jetzt gerade gesagt, wir sind hier relativ nah am Nördhimmel. Ich habe aber hier leider auch gemerkt, wo ebenso die Grenzen des Hackens und des Bastelns sind. Das war relativ überraschend und auch relativ unangenehm. Denn wo ich hierher gekommen bin, dachte ich ebenso, naja, klasse, Sternwarte, die braucht ja irgendwie hier IT, das machst du mal, das kannst du so ein bisschen. Und dann habe ich sehr viel Zeit damit verschwendet, irgendwelche alten Geräte wieder zum Laufen zu bringen, habe sogar mal eine ganze Serie von Tests gemacht, wie schwachbrüßig darf eigentlich ein Desktop-PC sein, bevor es so richtig wehtut. Bis heute ist unser zentraler Server hier zum Beispiel ein Dual P2 400, also das ist glaube ich jetzt auch schon seit fünf Jahren als lächerlich zu bezeichnen, vielleicht schon seit sechs Jahren. Es rentiert sich nicht, das hat sich leider rausgestellt. Es gibt auch hier sehr viele kleine...
Was rentiert sich nicht?...
Basteln und alte Technik refurbischen und wieder verwenden und da viel Arbeit reinstecken. Aber eben auch das Hacken, wenn es darum geht, irgendwelche Probleme, die auftreten im Bereich Steuerungstechnik oder Kommunikationstechnik mit irgendwelchen kreativen Sachen zu überbrücken. Denn wir haben hier relativ wenig Zeit. Jeder der Leute hat zwar so ein bisschen sein Spezialgebiet, aber unterm Strich muss eben auch das Dach dicht sein. Und irgendwann, jetzt zum Beispiel am nächsten Wochenende, oder jetzt am Wochenende, wollen wir den Empfänger rausnehmen. Das heißt, jeder, der auch nur annähernd höhentauglich ist, muss da irgendwie jetzt ran und mithelfen und oben dieses Gerät aus dem Fokus rausbringen. Das heißt also, da kommt man dann eben nicht dazu, seine eigentlichen Sachen in Ruhe zu machen, die man gerne machen wollte. Und wir sind deshalb sehr schnell dazu übergegangen, Probleme mit neuer Technik zu lösen. Es ist natürlich immer interessant, wenn man da kreative Lösungen entwickelt und implementiert. Aber wir haben jetzt eben auch das Problem, dass muss, wenn es mal ausfällt, muss es irgendwie ersetzbar sein. Das ist einfach, wenn ich das gleiche Gerät nachkaufen muss. Das ist nicht so einfach, wenn ich mir erstmal eine Platine erhitzen muss. Und es ist wie gesagt auch erfahrungsgemäß einfach so, dass dieser Versuch eben alte Rechner hier zu recyceln, der hätte uns zwar ein bisschen Geld gespart, aber eben lang nicht so viel, wie an Arbeitszeit verloren geht. Das steht einfach in keinem Verhältnis. Das ist vielleicht was anderes, wenn es darum geht, irgendwie eine Kamera jetzt an unseren optischen Teleskope anzuflanschen. Also Webcam-Astronomie ist ja so ein stehendes Ding, das macht man ja nun mal so. Für den Rest hat sich es eben wie gesagt nicht bewährt. Und ich mache hier im Prinzip ja im Moment IT-mäßig eigentlich das, was man halt in der Firma auch machen würde. Und ja, so ein bisschen die andere Sache, die immer noch wichtig ist bei so was, ist vielleicht jetzt auch für ein paar höhere interessant. Wie sieht das eigentlich organisationsmäßig aus? Also wir sind jetzt hier quasi angekommen, haben mit unseren Geldgebern gesprochen, haben mit Versicherungen gesprochen, mit der Stadt, mit Leuten, die uns also Genehmigungen geben und hatten hier eine ganz komische Idee. Also niemand hat Erfahrungen mit Radiosterne, niemand weiß, wie man sowas versichert, niemand weiß, was da jetzt eigentlich wirklich gefordert ist. Und da ist eben eine ganz wichtige Sache. Wir sind hier ganz eindeutig ein Verein, der den Leuten was für ihre Freizeit bieten will. Das heißt, wir können niemandem Vorschriften machen, wir können hier keine Hierarchie aufbauen wie in der Firma. Aber es ist sehr wichtig, dass man da eine gewisse Organisation reinbringt. Und das ist so eine Sache, die auch dann oft mal ein bisschen Konflikte mit sich bringt. Denn auf der einen Seite will ich niemand vorschreiben, was er hier zu tun hat. Auf der anderen Seite muss aber am Sonntag wieder Strom im Steuerraum sein. Das sind eben Sachen, die ein bisschen schwierig sind. Da gibt es auch einen Design-Pattern dazu. Das hat bei uns nicht so richtig gut funktioniert. Und da ist auch ein bisschen das Problem, das ist vielleicht überraschend, dass wir ein bisschen Probleme mit der technischen Kommunikation haben. Wir haben gar nicht so viele Leute, die Routine haben im Verwenden von Wikis oder Mailing-Disten oder sonstigen Sachen. Dazu kommt eben noch, dass man den Leuten natürlich nichts vorschreiben kann und auch nicht will. Wir wollen ja auch gar keine Hierarchie eigentlich haben. Gelegentlich braucht man es. Das ist eine ganz schwierige Sache. Da haben wir auch kein Patentrezept dafür gefunden. Aber das ist durchaus etwas, was man im Kopf behalten sollte, wenn man so ein Projekt angeht.
Nachvollziehbar.
Ja, das ist...
Trotzdem seid ihr weitergekommen, als ihr es schon ursprünglich gedacht habt.
Es hat eigentlich wirklich so weit gut funktioniert, war aber deshalb natürlich auch manchmal stressiger, als es hätte sein müssen.
Tja, there's no free lunch.
Genau.
Jetzt sind wir aber durch. Ja, der Astropeiler. Nichts für Astroverpeiler, aber hier kann man sich auf jeden Fall sehr breitbandig einbringen. Wer jetzt hier nicht unbedingt gleich ein Praktikum anfangen will, aber einfach nur mal Bock hat, sich das alles anzuschauen, die Türen stehen hier immer offen oder habt ihr das so mit Besuchern?
Die Türen stehen leider nicht immer offen, weil nicht immer jemand da ist, aber wer auch immer Interesse hat, kann sich einfach kurz über unsere Webseite melden, www.astropeiler.de, da gibt es ein Kontaktformular und da machen wir einfach kurz was aus und gucken uns das hier in Ruhe mal an. Ansonsten haben wir auch von Mai bis Oktober jeden Sonntag um 14 Uhr eine Führung und einen Fachvortrag hier vor Ort. Den kann man sich natürlich auch mal anschauen, aber ich finde es eigentlich immer sehr viel schöner, wenn man in aller Ruhe mit nur einer Person hier mal durchgeht und sich mal die ganze Technik ein bisschen anguckt.
Aber wenn jetzt so ein kompletter Hackerspace hier mal auflaufen will, dann sagt er auch nicht nein?
Da sagen wir natürlich auch nicht nein.
Okay, das ist ja ein schönes Geekend hier, so, wenn man mal die ganzen Kramsichtchen anschaut.
Das ist übrigens auch durchaus so, dass wir sehr froh wären, wenn sich Leute von weit weit wegmelden würden, vielleicht auch gerne über Skype oder so. Wir haben auch Sachen, die man von beliebig irgendwo machen kann. Also das fängt an beim Webseite mitbetreiben, das geht bis hin zu Geräte entwickeln, bauen und uns dann zukommen lassen per Post, da geht also ganz viel.
Oder vielleicht mal ein Wikia aufsetzen und den ganzen Kram hier auch zu dokumentieren, elektronisch.
Dokumentation, ja.
Na gut, jetzt haben wir hier aber genug Arbeitsamt gespielt. Jürgen, super, tolles Projekt hier, ich bin echt beeindruckt, es ist einfach ein krasser Ort.
Ja, freut mich.
Ich hoffe, das geht hier noch voran. Und voran geht es hier auch mit CAE, aber das war es jetzt erstmal hier für diese Ausgabe und es geht bald weiter und ich finde es super, dass hier immer noch alle dabei bleiben und ich sorge mich darum, dass es auch so bleibt. Sagt Tschüss und bis bald bei CAA.